[Musique]
Guillaume Bigot bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter sucintement je peux Guillaume
Bigot je suis né le 14 novembre
1969 à Paris et je après une vingtaine
d'années dans l'enseignement supérieur
où j'ai j'ai donné des cours et dirigé
surtout des écoles de commerce je suis à
présent chroniqueur éditorialiste sur C
news et sur Sun
radio j'ai vu sur votre sur vos
antécédents que vous aviez un passé de
militaire oh j'ai dans ma génération on
a fait son service militaire vous étiez
dans les services d'enseignement
non je je pas commenter ça je pense que
voilà c'est pas c'est un c'est la DRM
j'ai pas de de ça commence bien c'est
besoin d'en connaître mais je pense que
vous connaissez ce concept du besoin
d'en connaître tout à fait là où
nécessité fait
loin on a décidé de vous faire venir
aujourd'hui pour discuter un petit peu
de d'école de commerce de journalisme de
prospective de tout un tas de sujet à
ride de peut-être de ces news et de
peut-être d'autres choses de des or bien
et j'en passais des
meilleurs école de commerce est-ce que
c'est encore
une c'est pas un peu d'une vacuité pas
possible un manque de prisme de lecture
dans un système qui est qui n'a plus
besoin d'eux comment ça se passe alors
c'est c'est intéressant je je d'abord
rien ne me prédisposait à travailler
dans les dans les écoles de commerce
c'est pas ce que j'avais prévu de faire
dans la vie et j a été entraîné
j'appartenais à à ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un S tank un groupe de
réflexion euh qui s'appelait la
Fondation Marc block alors ça date hein
c'est très très ancien Mar block P ceux
qui ne savaient pas qui ne savent pas un
un historien
remarquable école des anales et cetera
mais aussi quelqu'un qui était pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale au début
pendant la drôle de guerre qui était
affecté à l'approvisionnement aux
essences et qui ensuite a constaté de
visus et de très près l'enchaînement de
la catastrophe et qui a ra une analyse
au scalpel qui s'appelle une étrange
défaite voilà et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on avait récupéré le nom Marc
block c'était une sorte de bande de
souverainiste de droite de gauche enfin
il y avait Henry Guo je pense que Tod
peut-être était dans le coup à ce
moment-là qu'il m'en veuille pas s'il
était pas dans le coup régiste de Bray
enfin elisabeth Lévy enfin voilà moi
j'étais un gamin là-dedans et j ai
rencontré quelqu'un qui va devenir mon
co-auteur enfin qui est devenu mon coaur
auteur qui s'appelle Jean-Claude barreau
qui a eu de multiples vies euh qui que
je considère quasiment comme un comme un
maître euh quelqu'un qui qui a fondé les
éditions Stock qui a été dans la
diplomatie qui a été dans l'entourage de
François mitteran et qui est aussi fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de bouquins et on
fera ensemble deux livres toute
l'histoire du monde chez Fayard et toute
la géographie du monde et en fait comme
il travaillait avec Charles pascois et
que Charles pascois avait créé dans le
département des haut scè ce qu'il a
intitulé le Pôle Universitaire Léonard
VCI qui se composait en fait de trois
écoles une école de management école au
commerce on va y revenir une école de
multimédia et une école d'ingénieur et
qu' y donnait des courses Jean-Claude
barraau il m'a dit mais viens donner des
cours dans dans cette école et en fait
on a commencé un cours qui ressemble
quand même à l'ascension de l'Éverest en
tong c'est-à-dire raconter à des élèves
qui sortaient de du bac en école
d'ingénieur en école de commerce leur
raconter toute l'histoire du monde pour
réhabiliter la chronologie pour
réhabiliter les batailles enfin faire
d'une sorte de de malais Isaac et de ce
cours va sortir ce livre et en fait les
écoles de commerce c'est un sujet
absolument passionnant parce que c'est
le point d'observation à mon avis de la
transformation de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'art du gouvernement du bon
gouvernement en gouvernance en
management et en fait la matrice elle
est là le le le le paradigme il est
téléchargé dans les écoles de commerce
bien sûr il est est téléchargé aux
États-Unis alors si on on j'ai fait un
petit bouquin sur les écoles de commerce
qui s'appelle la trahison des chefs chez
faayard et en fait d'abord ça ça
commence par un paradoxe c'est que ce ce
modèle totalement anglo-saxon à
l'origine il est français il y a un
ingénieur de de du côté de Saint-Étienne
des mines l'École des Mines de la fin du
19e début du 20e siècle qui fait un
bouquin assez fondateur et qui pose en
fait les bases de ce qui va devenir le
management contemporain qui va être
ensuite repris transformé avec
différentes étapes on pas rentrer dans
dans toutes les étapes et dans tous les
détails mais ça va se transformer et ça
va se solidifier et juste pour que les
gens qui nous regardent comprennent dans
les écoles de commerce qu'est-ce qu'on y
apprend on y apprend un certain nombre
d'outillage c'est un outillage en fait
assez technique la comptabilité en
partie double le marketing les
ressources humaines le droit du travail
et cetera bon chacun de ces outils n'est
pas dépourvu d'intérêt le problème c'est
que ça se réifie en une sorte de modèle
en une sorte de paradigme qui fait qu'en
réalité on va en appliquant ces modèles
à mon avis faire exactement exactement
tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire pour
diriger les hommes tout ce que de
manière intuitive de
manière on
dirait enfin instinctive l'être humain a
fait depuis les premières parties de
chasse du néolitique jusque dans les
années 70 pour diriger des groupes
humains et quand je dis des groupes
humains c'est tous les groupes humains
vous soyez patron d'un bureau de poste
ou vous soyez président d'une
association à la tête d'un État ou à la
tête d'une multinationale diriger des
hommes ça a toujours été à peu près ce
qu'on pourrait appeler l'art du bon
gouvernement l'art du bon gouvernement
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est encourager les
gens c'est connaître les gens c'est
s'intéresser à ses collaborateurs c'est
déléguer un maximum parce qu'un un
dirigeant sait qu'il ne peut pas tout
faire par lui-même mais c'est aussi
dirigé au nom d'un bien commun au nom
d'un intérêt général et ça il y a pas
besoin de le théoriser il y pas besoin
d'avoir lu mayavel ou Platon pour le
savoir et pour le sentir et bien ça le
paradigme du management le paradigme des
écoles de commerce qui est enseigné en
école de commerce c'est un acide qui est
destiné à dissoudre cette idée d'intérêt
général de sorte qu'on apprend aux
dirigeants que diriger ce n'est plus un
art et Bonaparte dit le commandement
virgule c'est un art simple et tout
d'exécution et ça c'est encore une fois
ce qui correspond à un art et ce qui
correspond à ce qui avait toujours été
fait pour diriger des groupes humains et
bien le management va remplacer ça par
une science plus un art une science avec
un certain nombre d'outils de
méthodologie qui va permettre en fait de
d'optimiser sous contrainte dans
l'intérêt de celui qui dirige c'està que
celui qui dirige de va plus diriger au
nom d'un intérêt commun et au nom d'un
intérêt général il va diriger dans son
intérêt donc ça va être un art tout de
manipulation c'est même plus un art
c'est une science d'ailleurs et ça va
être quelque chose qui qui s'est répandu
d'abord dans les grandes entreprises et
ensuite qui s'est répondu maintenant à
la tête de l'état de sorte qu'à la tête
de l'État nous n'avons plus de
dirigeants politiqu nous avons des
managers et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les bons managers du privé avant
étaient de bons politiques entre
guillemets et à l'inverse maintenant les
politiques sont de bons managers mais le
bon manager est quelqu'un qui très
habilement arrive à tirer la couverture
à lui et à profiter de sa position de
pouvoir dans son intérêt propre mais
c'est pas quelqu'un qui fait fructifié
un intérêt général puisque par
définition il y croit pas alors il
faudrait peut-être un peu ouvrir le
capot de ce management de savoir ce
qu'il y a à l'intérieur dans votre
bouquin dans votre livre toute
l'histoire du monde
oui de la préhistoire à nos jours vous
avez prophétiser quoi le 11 septembre
non pas dans pas dans ce livre j'ai rien
prophétisé mais c'est le premier bouquin
que j'ai fait qui s'appelle les SEP
scénario de l'Apocalypse chez flamarion
mais ça ça c'est justement le cours
qu'on a fait avec Jean-Claude barreau et
qui est devenu un quasi un BR enfin a dû
traduire ça dans 11 langues c'est vendu
à plus de 200000 exemplaires cétait un
très gros succès parce que les étudiants
nous le disaient déjà en cours vous
c'est comme si vous aviez allumé la
lumière ça vous nous avez rendu une
profondeur historique une une mémoire
parce que finalement
sur sur le premier comment vous avez
fait pour anticiper ou comment vous avez
pu imaginer des attentats à
manatan le mode opératoire je l'ai pas
je l'ai pas
anticipé et la ville bon parce que c'est
un symbole important c'est surtout
Al-Qaïda la dangerosité de benadad en
fait ce livre Les se scénarios
d'apocalypse qui est sorti en 2000 donc
rédigé en 99 parait d'un postulat qui
est euh la mondialisation heureuse c'est
une folie on était dans les dividendes
de la paix on était même dans la guerre
sans mort avec des bombes téléguidées
qui allaient tuer les gens tuer les
ennemis vivants et donc nous n'avons
nous n'avions plus d'ennemis et nous
étions protégés par les États-Unis
d'Amérique et donc on allait vers un
univers dans lequel tous les gars du
monde allaient se donner la main on
parlait pas encore de start-up mais
enfin quoi que si dans les années 2000
on parlait déjà des start-ups et le
livre Les SEP scénarios de l'Apocalypse
vise à attaquer à la racine ce postulat
c'est-à-dire de dire la guerre de haute
intensité tôt ou tard sera de retour
parce que la guerre est dans les gêne de
l'être humain parce qu'il y a une
pulsion agressive dans l'être humain et
parce que la la difficulté de l'être
humain c'est vivre sur un territoire en
groupe et se mettre d'accord sur la
définition du juste et de l'injuste et
ça à toutes les générations les êtres
humains se doivent recommencer euh à
déterminer ce qui est juste et injuste à
à l'intérieur d'une cité et entre les
cités il y a entre les modes
d'organisation politique il y a
forcément des tensions il y a des
tensions liées à des valeurs qui peuvent
être différentes des définitions du
juste et de l'injuste qui peuvent être
incompatibles mais bien sûr lié à des
questions de matières premières lié à
des questions énergétiques liées à des
toutes sortes de rivalités et même
parfois la guerre souvent parce que le
paradigme de la guerre ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer dans C scénario de
l'Apocalypse c'est que souvent le
paradigme de la guerre c'est Hitler
enfin c'était Hitler c'est et d'ailleurs
ça reste Hitler avec l'affaire de
l'Ukraine et Poutine c'estàd on attend
que on d'avoir un ennemi qui soit un
ennemi paradigmatique un ennemi qui veut
la guerre en tant que tel qui estime que
la guerre est souhaitable et nécessaire
en tant que tel ce qui est probablement
l'idée d'Hitler d'Hitler mais en réalité
la plupart des conflits et même des
conflits très graves se déclench non pas
parce que l'un des protagonistes veut la
guerre mais parce qu'il peut y avoir
simplement de la méfiance ou une une
espèce de théorie des jeux ou ne sais
pas si tu vas m'agresser tu ne sais pas
si je vais t'agresser mais la peur la
tension on ne sait pas ce que l'autre
pense en fait on sait pas ce que l'autre
a dans la tête et et et donc on ne sait
pas parce qu'on fait pas de
renseignement parce qu'on connaît pas la
langue parce qu'on a pas de diplomate
parce qu'on a pas de capteur sur place
parce qu' on fait pas un travail de long
terme on fait pas de travail en
profondeur c'est on ne sait pas ce que
l'autre a dans la tête pour moi c'est un
argument qui est caduc c'est-à-dire
queon fait pas l'effort
comment mais ça ça c'est une partie r
pas faire non c'est parce que dans ces
années-là en 2000 en tout cas et c'est
un peu moins vrai aujourd'hui on a
l'impression c'est l'histoire de la fin
c'est la fin de l'histoire c'est on a
l'impression que l'autre ce qu'il a dans
la tête c'est de vouloir devenir comme
soi tous les tous tous les gars du monde
veulent devenir des Occidentaux veulent
que leur supermarché soit plein veulent
se se se voir les mêmes séries et cetera
donc on on arrive à la station terminale
de l'humanité donc donc ça va faire
tomber les motifs de guerre de plus on a
cette impression aussi ce qui est vrai
que contrôler du territoire là avec la
guerre en Ukraine on revient à la des
problématiques de matières premières de
de contrôle du territoire pour les
matières premières Rémont Haron dans un
article intéressant vers la fin des
années 70 dit effectivement la détention
enfin le le la la la guerre de contrôle
de territoire n'a plus tellement de sens
après l'airre industrielle sauf
évidemment à pouvoir mettre la main
faire main basse sur des ressources
limitées dont on peut tirer une rente
comme évidemment les matières premières
mais sur ces SEP scénarios de
l'Apocalypse moi mon idée elle est très
simple elle est de dire à partir du
moment où la conflictualité c'est une
sorte de malédiction humaine dont on ne
sortira jamais on on peut pas on n pas
condamné à faire la guerre mais
effectivement c'est la dage la dage
romain qui wi pasme parabelhomme c'est
qui veut la paix prépare la guerre à
cette condition on peut installer une
dissuasion et on peut rechercher
intelligemment un intérêt commun avec
ceux qui ne pensent pas comme comm nous
ceux qui n'ont pas les mêmes intérêts
que nous tout en sachant et tout en
craignant que la guerre revienne et le
paradoxe c'est quand on craint que la
guerre revienne on peut l'empêcher de
survenir si on n'est pas attentif au
fait que la guerre peut revenir ou si on
se fait croire que les raisons de la
guerre disparaissent on peut être comme
le dit Robert Musil dans un homme sans
qualité en 1418 nous avions été tels des
voyageurs de wagon lit on a été percuté
en pleine nuit voilà et c'est ça l'idée
c'est qu'en 1418 il y a un bouquin
célèbre d'un anglais qui s'appelle
Norman Engle ver 1912 913 qui dit mais
l'Allemagne l'Empire allemand à l'époque
et la Grande-Bretagne au Royaume-Uni ont
tellement d'intérêt croisé
capitalistique financier et cetera que
la guerre la guerre est impensable entre
l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne on est
en 1913 on sait ce qui va advevenir et
donc je prends SEP régions du monde SEP
conflits qui sont très connus et tu vas
voir je vais répondre à ta question euh
il est question bien sûr de par exemple
de Inde Pakistan il est question euh euh
de l'Ukraine et de la Russie déjà dans
ce dans ce bouquin il est question de
Taïwan et de la Chine et des États-Unis
et cetera et cetera enfin je vais pas
tous les égrainer et euh il est question
notamment d'Al-Qaïda de Ben Laden parce
que c'est extrêmement c'est déjà une une
organisation qui s'est fait connaître
depuis 1998 avec des attentats euh
particulièrement bien montés et et et et
le personnage est particulièrement
déterminé c'est alors donc la réponse à
cette question c'est que Ben Laden était
déjà connu comme le lOUPBLANC par les
gens qui s'intéressaient à ces questions
on savait on connaissait le profil de ce
de ce personnage on savait qu'il était
peut-être pas lui-même AG guéri mais en
tout cas qu'il avait une grande
expérience de la logistique de
l'organisation qu'il avait des moyens
financiers importantsp de l'Afghanistan
à l'époque de l'Afghanistan bien sûr et
puis il avait le le secours le mjahidin
c'est Ben Laden pour le pour le resituer
c'est un peu le c'est c'est un
personnage qui est comparable à la
faillette quoi non mais s'il vous plaît
on me compare pas la faillette à Ben
merci d'abord Ben Laden est un
personnage épouvantable sur le plan
éthique contrairement à à la fillette je
suis bien d'accord avec vous encore que
de notre point de vue à nous occidental
du point de vue d'un d'un d'un islamiste
je suis pas certain que Ben Len soit un
repoussoir et d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un
qui qui a dont la notoriété ne cesse de
de d'augmenter donc vous buvez la
faillette premier citoyen d'honneur
français aux États-Unis alors justement
derrière cette histoire de la fillette
on nous fait croire que la bataille de
own et l'indépendance des États-Unis ce
sont les Insurgents comme on dit les les
les les sujets de Sa Gracieuse Majesté
qui ne voulait plus payer d'impôt sur
l'importation des boîtes de thé qui se
sont révolté qui ont gagné avec leur
petit bras avec leur petites armes la
bataille la guerde d'indépendance en
réalité c'est une intervention militaire
française navale et terrestre massive
qui dont la tête et le général rochambau
voilà c'est c'est c'est cette
intervention décidée par Louis XV c'est
la France qui va accoucher des
États-Unis d'Amérique donc on a fait
effectivement la France a fait beaucoup
de bêtises dans l'histoire et le général
a faillette là-dedans qu'est-ce qu'il
vient faire le héros des des Amériques
les quand George Bush junior disait du
mal de la France il disait du mal de la
France avec le le portrait de la
fillette au-dessus de lui mais en fait
les Américains ont préféré se souvenir
de la fillette c'est moins humiliant
pour eux puisqu'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils se sont libérés tout seul de la
tutelle anglaise alors en fait c'est une
intervention militaire de la France et
cela fillette c'était un c'était un
personnage c'était une personne privée
en fait c'est quelqu'un c'est un fils de
famille qui avait de l'argent qui avait
du temps et qui était fasciné par les
idées du temps les idées de l'époque et
les idées de l'époque c'était les idées
euh de de des lumières c'était créer une
sorte d'utopie républicaine à l'autre
bout du monde et gagné par ces idées qui
ne sont pas encore des idées
révolutionnaires he on est on est avant
la révolution sur ces deners personnel
la faillette va se transporter de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique et faire le
coup de feu et donc vous voyez il y a
quand même un un un parallèle avec Ben
Laden Ben Laden est un fils c'est le
fils bug en fait c'est pas le fils buig
non c'est pas le fils bug allez-y
allez-y alors donc c'est un fils d'une
branche de la royauté
saoudienne continuer non mais c'est
surtout une très grande famille les Ben
Laden d'origine yéménite de la la
dramaout qui sont qui ont fait fortune
en Arab Arabie Saoudite parce que ce
sont un peu les rois du BTP en Arabie
Saoudite donc ce gars aurait pu se la
couler douce à ibissa et comme le reste
de sa famille voilà dérouler une vie de
Playboy très très argenté et cetera mais
il est gagné par les idée de l'époque en
79 c'est la
révolution islamique en Iran à téran ça
va atteindre quand même le monde le
monde sunnite benaden tout le monde sait
que c'est un c'est un
sunite et il y a une espèce de de de de
retour comme ça de la mystique du djihad
et c'est le moment où l'Union soviétique
envahit l'Afghanistan donc il devient
très très
tendance pour pour les jeunes Afghans
pardon pour les jeunes Saoudiens qui
s'ennuient un peu d'aller faire le coup
de feu alors beaucoup ne franchissent
pas la frontière ils sont pris en charge
par le grand allié de l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est-à-dire le le Pakistan et avec le
service de de renseignement du Pakistan
qui est bien connu
l'Isis intern secret intelligence qui
qui est en réalité dont le surnom est le
secret le soldat secret de l'islam
invisible enfin le soldat invisible de
l'islam pardon IIS c'est invisible sold
of Islam et donc là on connaît cette
histoire la CIA va les États-Unis vont
se venger du Vietnam le Vietnam où les j
américains ont été tués certes par des
Vietnamiens mais avec l'aide logistique
du KGB et là la CIA va rendre à l'Armée
rouge la monnaie de sa pièce si j'ose
dire en finançant la guerria afghane qui
essaie de chasser les troupes
soviétiques qui ont franchi la frontière
en
79 donc merci pour ce petit cours
d'histoire ou ce
petit ce rafraîchissement de tout le
monde tout le monde sait ça je pense le
parallèle avec le fils le fils dans le
BTP bon c'était un petit peu des U ou
même pas du tout mais ça permettait de
rappeler que c'est la France qui a
couché militairement au États-Unis pour
pour pour revenir à ce qui se passe en
ce moment où on voit des curelles
intestines des armées qui se rendent de
la la de la pièce qui se rendent le le
coup de gourdin on va où avec une
raréfaction des ressources des
difficultés à à maintenir 2200 calories
par tête de PIP dans les pays
occidentaux avec des tensions de guerre
économique qui n'ont pas été anticipées
en France et en Europe comment vous
voyez le le la suite de l'histoire
d'abord pour l'Europe et ensuite pour la
France vous voulez m'entraîner sur un
sur un terrain je veux pas vous non non
non non mais mais la question la
question incite quand même à se poser
des questions qui sont des questions je
dirais matérielles qui sont des
questions aussi pratipratique vous avez
raisonénergie c'est fondamental résumer
trèvalement c'est est-ce que l'Europe va
se faire dépesser sur l'hôtel de la
mondialisation et la France sera le Lamb
beau de chair pendouillant d'un cadavre
mort
vivant alors là pour répondre à cette
question il faut savoir si la France va
rester dans la trajectoire qui a été
fixée par sa classe dirigeante on va
dire depuis à peu près 40 ans euh Act
unique
puis construction
Maastricht puis traité de Lisbonne et
édification d'une sorte de
d'État enfin c'est pas un état
d'ailleurs c'est il voudrait que ce soit
un état c'est la déclaration récente de
dragy mais enfin une espèce de de saut
dans l'inconnu post démocratique post
nationale avec une organisation
juridico-buraucratique très molle en
fait qui qui agrège les États nations et
les démocraties et qui les vident un peu
de leur substance pour faire pour faire
l'Europe est-ce que la France va rester
là-dedans s'il reste là-dedans ah bah
c'est certain que l'euro qui était déjà
la variable justement du dollar euh et
qui a commis cet exploit absolument
insensé d'être à la fois à la merci des
Chinois et à la fois à la mercie des
Américains plutôt économiquement et
commercialement des Chinois et
plutôt stratégiquement et militairement
des Américains là pour le coup la France
et les autres acteurs de cette union
européenne risquent d'être bel et bien
dépessés effectivement d'autant plus
dépessé que la guerre en Ukraine euh
j'is dire à à à abîmé euh l'acteur le
plus le plus solide de ce système
européen qui est l'Allemagne en fait
l'Allemagne c'est pas l'homme malade de
l'Europe l'Allemagne ça devient l'homme
malade de l'Europe en fait l'Allemagne
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'Europe il faut
revenir peut-être à l'origine qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette idée d'Europe et on
va faire la jonction avec le management
on va essayer euh le
management c'est une c'est une illusion
de vouloir diriger toutes les sociétés
humaines et en particulier les états
come on dirige les entreprises et c'est
de vouloir les diriger sans bien commun
sans intérêt général sachant que l'idée
de bien commun ou d'intérêt général peut
varier du tout au tout si vous êtes chez
Al-Qaïda ou si vous êtes
euh à la tête de la de la Belgique vous
avez pas la même définition du bien
commun mais on peut imaginer que pour
diriger efficacement il faut avoir une
une définition du bien commun il faut
avoir une stratégie il faut avoir
quelque chose qui en fait qu'est-ce que
c'est le bien commun c'est quelque chose
qui va relier les dirigeants ou diriger
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre
d'exercer l'autorité la fameuse autorité
qu'on cherche partout qu'est-ce que
c'est l'autorité c'est quand les
dirigeants et les dirigés partagent une
même échelle de valeur se reconnaissent
dans les mêmes buts ce qui signifie que
le dirigant dans les mêmes
sanctions un minimum oui forcément même
si le dirigé a plus de chance ou plus de
moyens d'échapper à la sanction mais en
tout cas il faudra pas trop que ça se
voit parce que un dirigeant sensé bah un
dirigant sensé une anecdote à cet égard
pour montrer à quel point euh la la
notion d'intérêt général il faut pas la
confondre avec le fait d'être d'être
sincère ou pas sincère on s'en fiche que
les dirigeants soient sincère ou pas
sincère l'essentiel c'est qu'ils soit
des c'est qu'ils se sentent obligés
c'est c'est la formule de l'Ancien
Régime noblesse oblige bon ça existait
avant la noblesse dans les tribus et ça
existe bien après la noblesse noblesse
oblige toujours parce qu'un dirigeant
doit toujours se sentir obligé parce
qu'il lui permet d'exercer l'autorité
sur les gens qu' le dirigent on m'a
raconté que et c'est une anecdote je
pense
exacte que François mitéran c'est je
pense ou je suis
sûr non je su je suis sûr quand j'ai
vérifié moi-même là j'ai pas V pas vérif
par construction si si parce que vous
allez voir c'est assez éclairant non
mais si c'est éclairant d'un brun
couloir ça éclair rien du tout je suis
pas d'accord avec vous il y a des a des
anecdotes d'ailleurs qui mériteraient un
peu comme certaines fleurs sont fausses
sont tellement belles qu'ell mais
qu'elles sont plus belles que les vraies
certaines anecdotes même si elles sont
fausses sont quand même pleines
d'enseignement donc là en l'occurrence
on on on je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais DSK on l'avait vu dans une
dans une voiture de luxe une Porsche
quelque chose comme ça euh il est il
voulait à priori se présenter au nom de
la gauche François miteron on sait que
c'est un homme qui aimait vivre qui
aimait les belles choses les belles
femmes et cetera qui était les femmes
sont pas des choses j'ai dis des belles
choses et des belles femmes bien sûr
sont pas des choses comment avez pensé
une chose pareille euh j'ai pas entendu
votre ponctuation c'est pour ça très
bien je vais essayer de de rendre
audible mais mais
virgules et bien François mitteran
secrétaire général du Parti socialiste
qui s'était pas encore présenté à la
présidence de la République secrétaire
général du Ps donc parti de gauche à
l'époque un vrai parti même de masse
mais très à gauche on lui propose un
grand publicitaire qui est encore connu
qui parle beaucoup de gens de qui ont
réussi ou pas leur vie en ayant des Relx
avant 50 ans lui propose
de le raccompagner chez lui au volant
d'un véhicule de luxe c'est votre
anecdote c'est ça ce qu'on vous a
rapporté et mitérant dit évidemmentce
vous a rapporté ça qui m'a rapporté ça
c'est le publicitaire en question c'est
Jacques voilà et Jacques segela mitan
dit à Jacques seggel mais vous
plaisantez je suis secrétaire général du
Parti socialiste il est hors de question
que je monte dans une dans une voiture
de sport et une voiture de luxe alors
c'est pas on voit bien que François
mitteran c'est quelqu'un qui pouvait
jouer avec les règles qui était tout à
fait cynique on l'appelait le Florentin
et cetera c'est pas une affaire c'est
pas du tout une affaire
de je dirais de sincérité mais il se
sentait obligé par sa charge il était
pas encore président de la République
mais ilincarnait un parti de gauche donc
pour lui c'était incompatible de faire
ça alors je mettrais plus de N l'intérêt
général oblige je dirais qu'il sentait
pas obligé je pense qu'il était
calculateur mais c'est la même chose
d'accord c'est la même chose sauf
qu'aujourd'hui fort des enseignements
tirés des écoles de commerce ou du
paradigme des écoles de commerce
c'est-à-dire l'illusion suivant laquelle
on peut
gouverner en son nom propre et dans son
intérêt propre parce qu'en fait toute
idée du bien commun de l'intérêt général
a été dissoute a été dissoute à la fois
par le modèle du marché euh offre et
demande du modèle néo disons
néoclassique modèle d'économie pur et
parfait qui explique qu'il n'y a rien
there is no such thing a society comme
disait en
français la société n'existe pas il
n'existe que des intérêts
individuels ça c'est la dimension disons
un peu de droite un peu néoclassique un
peu libéral et de l'autre côté vous avez
le même acide qui va attaquer la notion
d'intérêt général qui vient plutôt de la
déconstruction de la gauche de toutes
ces pensées
euh des années des années 70 qui
maintenant voilà nous reviennent un peu
en boomerang sous forme de wisme et qui
attaque l'idée que quelque chose de plus
grand que l'individu enfin que
l'individu ne peut pas se suffire à
lui-même qu'il ne peut pas trouver en
lui-même sa propre fin il
s'inscrit dans une société qu'il dépasse
il s'inscrit dans un bien commun qu'il
dépasse et ça si on parle comme les
psychanalystes on appellera ça le sur
mooi et donc le le modèle d'économie
purure et parfait comme on peut dire la
déconstruction de la philosophie des
années
70 ça va attaquer du côté droit et du
côté gauche cette idée de sur moi de
sorte qu'il n'y a plus que l'individu de
sorte qu'il n'y a plus que le moi et
donc on a plus que des dirigeants qui ne
croient pas dans l'intérêt général pens
que l'intérêt général c'est un pur
prétexte c'est une c'est quelque chose
qui ne les oblige en rien et qu'ils vont
pouvoir gouverner au nom de l'individu
alors il y a donc un miroir entre le
fait que eux dirigent dans leur intérêt
et le fait qu'il propose comme modèle
d'organisation de la société une société
dans laquelle il n'y a rien audessus de
l'individu et qui permettent aux
individus de se réaliser eux-mêmes
d'aller au bout de leur rêv au bout de
leurs désirs au bout de
leur de leur
intérêt voilà et ça ça explique pourquoi
on peut avoir
des cette cette formule complètement
stupéfiante prononcée par le Président
de la République vous aller dans une
gare et dans une gare vous pouvez
croiser des gens qui ne sont rien là ça
veut dire que le masque tombe en fait
euh la vision du président de la
République c'est qu'il n'est plus du
tout obligé en fait par sa charge par sa
fonction après tout qu'il pense ça c'est
une chose qu'il le disent il est en
train de CER consciencieusement la
branche sur laquelle il est assis donc
je sais pas si ce que je vous raconte
est suffisamment clair je pense que
c'est l'idée d'intérêt général et de
bien commun qui a été attaqué à la
racine la France l'Europe dans tout ça
on va où on revient sur l'Europe
l'Europe c'est l'idée qu'on peut se
passer de la politique et la place d'une
organisation politique on va avoir une
organisation économique c'est vraiment
ça le le point de départ est-ce que je
peux vous demander de baser votre votre
analyse ou ton analyse d'une façon
beaucoup plus terre c'est-à-dire plus
pragmatique plus fonctionnel plus plus
opératif c'est-à-dire faire je suis
d'accord qu'il faut toujours faire des
parallèles avec l'histoire ou se
reconnecter à l'histoire pour pouvoir au
moins lire le présent et peut-être
anticiper l'avenir d'une façon concrète
avec la guerre avec les Russes où bah on
est un petit peu short et tong en terme
d'armement de production d'armement et
de de capacité à se réveiller
oui non on s'est un peu réveillé on
était en short on a rien
anticipé passons donc d'une façon plus
pragmatique concrètement maintenant
qu'est-ce qui nous attend pour les deux
prochaines années je vous demande même
pas à 5 ans donc pour les de deux
prochaines années pour l'Europe est-ce
que il y a une dislocation géopolitique
de l'Europe est-ce que ça va être
permettez-moi l'expression chacun son
cul et Dieu pour
tous est-ce que pour la France va y
avoir un système qui va freiser
entre la main sur le cœur nous sommes
drapés dans les dans les tendards de la
vertu des libertés mais concrètement
parlant on va se faire ravager notre
économie parce que bah on aura pas pris
des mesures proactives pour pouvoir
anticiper ce qui qui se passe en face
donc concrètement parlant vous êtes
optimiste pas optimiste comment ça va se
passer en terme économique en terme
militaire en terme
journalistique en terme d'anticipation
les répercussions à 5 10 15 ans sur
notre système éducatif notre système de
soins notre art de vivre à la française
les gens passai des meilleurs et ensuite
on passera sur les questions migratoires
dientre parce que là dientre oua là là
je vous laisse un boulevard pour choisir
ouais mais mais il faut il faut choisir
il faut Serrier un peu les problèmes
parce que là ça on part un peu dans dans
toutes les directions non si vous avez
un laser vous pouvez identifier les
problèmes je vous écoute euh
d'abord il me semble que Poutine a
quasiment emporté la partie c'est
difficile il faut pas trop s'avensurer
là-dessus parce que il y a eu tellement
de morts de part et d'autres qu'à un
moment ou un autre le front peut craquer
les choses peuvent se peuvent se se
renverser et cetera mais a priori ça
prend cette tournure là a priori à
l'heure où on parle les Américains
commencent à dire que ils ont plus
tellement d'armes à leur donner et
qu'ils ont plus tellement d'argent à
leur donner les élections américaines
s'approchent donc je pense que l'affaire
est un peu pliée pour Poutine 2uxème
considérant on aurait pu imaginer du
côté de l'Europe parce que le cœur de
l'Europe c'est l'économie c'est c'est
vraiment le fantasme de transformer
enfin de substituer une organisation
politique une organisation
économique bar traunion une organisation
juridique le tout étant axé sur
l'intérêt individuel pur c'est une
économie de marchés qui fonctionnent
dans l'intérêt individuel avec une
ouverture à la tolérance à toutes les
valeurs et tous les gens tous les gars
du monde viennent et s'installent comme
ils sont comme chez McDo et enfin c'est
un droit qui qui qui garantit si vous
voulez les contrats l'individu et cetera
et le gouvernement des j tout ça fait
système venez comme vous êtes avec ça
n'a rien à voir c'està-dire c'est on dit
pas venez comme vous êtes ah bah je
pense que l'idée de l'Europe c'est
de de substituer un état à des états
nation de substituer une sorte de zone
aéroportuaire de libre échange de de où
il y a une sorte de de il y a pas de
taxe et où les gens peuvent circuler
librement et ils viennent comme ils sont
si avec avec un renforcement de nous
sommes l'Europe on a plus de poids
économique donc on peut survivre alors
ça c'est ce qui a été vendu on peut on
peut survivre entre le bloc l'ancien
bloc communiste le bloc américain on
essaie de survivre en faisant un grand
bloc le problème c'est qu'on n pas la
même langue alors on fait un grand bloc
à la condition de de de de tout parier
sur le fait que le parapluie américain
militaire et stratégique va nous
protéger à vitam d'une part et d'autre
part qui aura même plus il y aura plus
de il y aura plus de conflit en fait
mais surtout à l'intérieur de ce de ce
système là on voit
que ce qui aurait pu enfin déclencher
une crise dans les 2 ans à venir sur
cette histoire de 2 ans relativement en
court terme c'est qu'il y ait un
différentiel parce qu'il y a eu des
différentiels très importants de
trajectoire économique de de de de de de
de croissance économique entre les pays
donc qui tirent le répingle du jeu et
d'abord l'Allemagne et les autres pays
notamment le nôtre et les pays du Sud et
c'était la crise de l'euro et c'était le
décrochage de la Grèce et comme
l'endettement français s'est accru
rapidement finalement je dis pas que
Poutine a rendu service à l'Europe mais
je dis que s'il y avait pas eu ce
problème gazier et euh cette inflation
importée et cette vraiment ce qui risque
de de d'être un un gros gros choc enfin
ce qui est déjà un gros choc économique
pour l'Allemagne les les les les
sentiers de croissance entre l'Allemagne
d'un côté et les autres pays européens
se serait écarté créant une tension qui
aurait pu faire effectivement à
relativement court terme faire sauter la
zone euro maintenant tous les pays de la
zone euro sont dans la mouise y compris
l'Allemagne y compris l'Allemagne ce qui
va peut-être effectivement avoir comme
effet euh de pousser comme ça a été le
cas avec dragi vous savez qu'il avait
accepté de refinancer contrairement à à
ce que les statuts de la BCE prévoi qui
interdisent totalement à la Banque
centrale européenne de refinancer des
obligations d'État et dragi avait pris
alors pas directement mais
indirectement sur sur le marché
secondaire racheter des obligations et
les refinancer là je pense que tout le
monde est tellement dans la panade il y
a tellement d'inflation et il y a
tellement de ralentissement de
croissance il y a tellement de déficit
même si l'Allemagne je crois je suis
sont à peu près à 60 pour d'endettement
de leur PIB donc ils sont très en
dessous de nous mais tout de même pour
eux ils vont devoir pousser cette
politique là donc je pense qu'à court
terme à mon je ne vois pas
l'euro exploser maintenant les
dirigeants européens sont toujours dans
cette folie de vouloir dépasser les
démocraties et les état naations en
fabriquant je je ne sais même pas
comment le qualifier d'ailleurs on parle
d'État et Mario Dragui a dit on va faire
un État européen mais somme toute
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un état c'est pas
nécessairement une démocratie un état
mais un état c'est au moins euh disons
une force obligatoire une force de
police une force militaire ce qui
implique depuis le démarrage des
premiers états un impôt la possibilité
de lever un impôt si vous pouvez lever
un impôt et si vous pouvez finalement
exercer une force de coerciss en clair
tuer c'est un état l'État c'est James
Bond il est licens to kill l'état il est
tout État est capable de de de donner la
mort les policiers sont armés les
militaires sont armés il faut pour ça
pouvoir prélever l'impôt et pour
prélever l'impôt protège aussi mais le
but n'est pas de tuer le but protège
évidemment qu'il protège l'armée protège
j'ai pas dit autre chose euh leur
capacité à tuer c'est supprimer c'est le
fameux truc de Weber c'est-à-dire le
monopole de la violence légitime
supprimer le la la possibilité au au aux
gens qui sont à l'intérieur de cette de
cet état donc les la population sur un
territoire donné soumis à un
gouvernement donné de de de régler leurs
conflit par la violence donc ça c'est le
monopole de l'État donc c'est c'est ça
l'état l'état ça suppose de lever un
impôt et d'entretenir une force publique
moi je vois une chose c'est que le seul
argent dont dispose l'Union européenne
c'est l'argent que les États veulent
bien lui donner l'Europe n'a absolument
pas la légitimité n'a pas la la force
morale ou psychologique suffisante pour
lever l'impôt si demain on vous dit on
lève un impôt européen Bruxelles lève un
impôt les gens vont se révolter et voyez
bien que cette capacité à lever un impôt
et être légitime pour lever un impôt et
tout à fait lié au fait que personne ira
se faire trouver la peau pour la zone
euro pourrait mourir pour le drapeau
français et de la même façon qu'on paye
ses impôts en France pas tous pour le
drapeau français j'ai l'impression en ce
moment non c'est une autre question
hélas d'ailleurs mais mais c'est pas
c'est pas une fatalité non plus mais on
va on va je sens que vous voulez passer
un autre un autre sujet mais on était
sur les 2 ans dans les 2 ans moi je vois
pas l'euro la zone euro explosé et et je
pense que ce ce ce projet à mon avis qui
se
déroule je dirais dans le avec le
désintérêt et et à mon avis le
le un air un peu l'air un peu gognard
des peuples enfin je pense que la
plupart des peuples européens regardent
leurs dirigeants sans comprendre
exactement ce qu'ils font parce que
pourquoi pourquoi ils comprennent pas
parce que si vous voulez les les
dirigeants nationaux qui sont
élus on peut les aimer ou pas mais enfin
bon même s'il y a beaucoup d'abstention
et je pense que la montée de
l'abstention évidemment est directement
corrélé à la à la à la fuite en avant
vers cet échelon européen vers le fait
de déplacer le pouvoir c'est votre
interprétation je pense que c'est oui
c'est mon interprétation mais je pense
qu'elle est assez vérifiable c'estàd que
après le référendum de 2005 si on reste
sur notre pays on voit bien que
l'abstention avant et après ne sont plus
du tout au même étiage au même niveau
j'ouvre une parenthèse par rapport à ce
que tu vous avez déjà évoqué le
management des états comme une
entreprise c'est ça si j'ai bien ça ici
il y a que des patrons vous êtes patron
de votre société oui bon quand il y a
des échecs comme ça qu'on a pu voir sur
l'anticipation des guerres
l'anticipation de l'inflation
l'anticipation des conflits dans une
entreprise vous faites quoi quand en
face de vous il y a pas de résultat des
merci bien vous rentrez chez vous
maintenant vous mettez une petite
enguelade vous essayez de sortir un
petit peu de former votre votre salarié
ou votre collaborateur pour qu'il soit
plus performant là en politique on a
toujours l'impression il y a jamais de
sanction bon mis à part le directeur de
la DRM qui a sauté la veille ou le le
surlendemain avec les
Russes là on n pas l'impression qu'il y
a des sanctions comme dans une
entreprise genre dans le privé pardon il
y a une sanction qui s'appelle
l'élection ouais non mais ça c'est
l'argument l'argument à gogo oh on va se
faire sanctionner dans les élections
Parti socialiste ils ont mangé B puis
ils ont bien mangé etair aussi de ex
parti de gouvernement qui trustaiit à
eux deux jusqu'à 80 % de de l'électorat
et donc un petit malin qui est arrivé
qui a fait bon on fait un peu des deux
et qui malin peut-être école de commerce
et en tout cas c'est l'inspiration oui
dans les dans les
boîtes on discute avec d'autres patrons
quand il y a un échec pareil les gens
ils se font virer à grand coup de piedan
alors je va je vais répondre à ça alors
je veux bien vous avez raison le Parti
socialiste bon ils ont morflé peut-être
les collections de montres ou des
conneries comme ça
mais euh je vois pas du tout à qui vous
faites allusion non plus très bien ça
tombe bien on a les mêmes non
allusions sur le le le évidemment que le
capitalisme a une corde de rappel
évidemment qu'il y a un compte de
résultat évidemment que les gens peuvent
pas perdre de l'argent à gogo bon ceci
est dit j'attire quand même votre
attention sur le fait que T attention
enfin laattention de tout le monde mais
la tienne oui
pardon sur le fait que le le la
gouvernance
d'entreprise a muté quand même elle a
muté je me permets un petit peu de
rentrer dans merci et là on va être
terre à TER justement la gouvernance
d'entreprise moi je vois pas trop ça
comme de la gouvernance je vois plutôt
ça comme de la cavalerie de la cavalerie
budgétaire c'est-à-dire que on est
mauvais mais on a le chéquier et on fait
de la dette donc je vois pas du tout de
gouvernance je vois surtout de la
cavalerie et tous les patrons qui nous
écoutent savent pertinemment ce que veut
dire la cavalerie mais là tu t'incris
pardon te couper mais tu t'es inscrit
dans une lecture qui est une lecture
assez néoclassique en disant un peu
comme dans le film là des
des sur ceux qui qui arrêtent de fumer
on dit fumer c'est
bien fumer fumer c'est pas bien pas
fumer c'est bien bon voilà là là le le
le modèle néoclassique dit le privé
voilà c'est ça le privé c'est bien le
public c'est pas bien d'accord donc le
privé il y a une sanction le public il y
a pas de sanction et ce bon c'est c'est
c'est vraiment le le l'argumentation
néoclassique je veux bien qu'on y
revienne mais ce qui me semble
intéressant euh pour faire la jonction
c'est de rappeler euh que cette on peut
dire explosion enfin des
des appelé la mondialisation financière
pour commencer avant qu'elle devienne
une mondialisation commerciale a permis
de transférer le poids du risque qui
pesait sur le capital au travail c'està
dire que pendant très longtemps le
capitalisme à l'origine c'est des gens
qui vont joue enfin qui vont engager
leur propre argent et qui risqu de le
perdre il risqu de le perdre il jouent
ils arrivent donc euh dans une situation
où ils font travailler des gens qui sont
salariés certes qui en croquent beaucoup
moins mais évidemment qui prennent
quasiment aucun risque et l'idée d'un
patron un peu à la Michelin paternaliste
mais c'est quand même un modèle qui est
bien un un ancré dans une espèce de de
de vision où il y a un surmis FAM
Michelin familial mais on retrouve ça
dans tous les pays capitalistes jusque
dans les années 70 60 70 du 20e siècle
on a l'idée que le dirigeant capitaliste
noblesse oblige pour lui il se fait for
de protéger ses salariés et c'est sa
responsabilité à lui si son argent est
perdu c'est son argent et qu'est-ce qui
va se passer avec cette ouverture des
marché financier à l'au des années 80
toute cette révolution néoclassique
libérale et cetera qu'est-ce qui va se
passer je je je vous donne la parole
tout de suite non je un bon patron c'est
ça oui mais ça ça reste les les patrons
de PME ça existe encore c'est pas une
PME non mais parce qu'il y a encore dans
les les grandes réussites les gens qui
réussissent brillamment dans le
capitalisme ça existe encore sont des
gens qui ont cette espèce d'éthique qui
ont encore un surmois bon mais c'est pas
le modèle des fonds de pension c'est pas
le modèle du turbo capitalisme qu'est-ce
qui se passe il se passe qu'un moment
ils vont ouvrir les marchés financiers
d'accord ces marchés financiers
vont permettre de deux choses ils vont
se dire le risque va désormais peser sur
les salariés et plus sur les détenteurs
du capital les détenteur du capital eux
ils veulent 15 % de roi si tu as 14 et
demi le blé il part immédiatement dans
une autre boîte qui est plus rentable
donc tu vois ils ont refilé le grisbe au
salariés qui va devenir la la variable
d'ajustement les salariés qu'est-ce qui
va se produire on dire ah oui mais il y
a maintenant une hausse des charges
sociales je connais ce discours par cœur
oui mais vous rendez compte la part des
dépenses publiques accru de manière
extraordinaire et cetera c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux et d'ailleurs ça devient
absolument malsin au bout d'un moment
non seulement l'impôt devient
confiscatoire mais à un moment tu peux
te poser la question de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'ils font avec ce pognon de dingue
comme dit l'autre soit mais c'est une
conséquence ce n'est pas une cause c'est
pas l'état qui s'est mis à croître c'est
le capitalisme qui a décidé de ne plus
prendre aucun risque et qui a décidé
surtout de s'investir et c'est le
deuxième effet qui se coule de cette
ouverture des marchés financiers de
s'investir là où le travail est le moins
cher possible et comme il s'est investi
là où le travail est moins cher possible
il a dégagé une survaleur il a exigé
d'ailleurs une survaleur et c'est comme
ça qu'on a eu si tu veux c c non
seulement cet écartement de revenu mais
cette psychologie cette nouvelle psych
du fait que finalement et bien on
pouvait come on pouvait jouir sans
entrave comme 10 68 on pouvait faire du
profit sans gêne ou sans entrave y
compris au détriment de son propre pays
y compris au détriment de ses salariés
et donc qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
management qu'est-ce que c'est que cet
art du management enfin cette science du
management c'est un moyen de noyer le
poisson de raconter aux gens pourquoi
c'est formidable de penser qu'ils vont
pas avoir d'augmentation de salaire
pourquoi c'est formidable de penser
qu'ils vont être viréré et cetera et
donc cette mentalité là s'est répandue
et c'est cette mentalité là qui
maintenant a déteint sur l'état et qu'on
voit à la tête de l'État mais en fait ni
l'État ni le le vrai capitalisme à
l'origine ne fonctionne comme ça il
fonctionne effectivement avec des cords
de rappel il fonctionne avec un sur moi
il fonctionne avec l'idée que le
dirigeant et les dirigés partagent un
intérêt général et qu'au nom de cet
intérêt général on peut réussir ou
échouer et si on échoue effectivement on
est sanctionné là c'est plus tout à fait
le cas là il un transfert de
responsabilité
dans un dans une idée qu'il n'y a plus
que l'individu il n'y a plus rien
audessus de l'individu et donc
l'individu il cherche à maximiser son
profit constamment et c'est à ça qu'on
aboutit aujourd'hui c'estàdire que le
jeune d'abord il y a plus de salariat le
salariat qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
s'incrire dans un collectif de travail
dans un dans un groupe dans un intérêt
général dans un cap dans un cap
qu'est-ce que veulent faire les les les
les plus jeunes ils veulent créer leur
propre boîte voilà donc il ils sont dans
une optique d'optimiser sous contrainte
de chercher leur intérêt leur intérêt
individuel et cetera de la même façon on
peut considérer que euh le le la
l'explosion des charges sociales
l'explosion des dépenses publiques avec
un cotisation sociale cotisation oui
parce que ça peut être vu effectivement
comme un revenu comme un un revenu
différé on cotise et puis ensuite on
récupère l'argent je suis d'accord avec
toi mais enfin les les niveaux de
prélèvement obligatoire deviennent
deviennent fous et grève bien sûr la
compétitivité mais il faut bien voir que
c'est un rés résultat c'est un résultat
d'une survaleur d'un surprofit qui a été
arraché par un capital qui s'est groupé
c'est l'inverse finalement du communisme
du du
ouvrier de tout pays ou ou prolétaire de
tout pays unissez-vous là les fonds de
pension c'est capitaliste ou détenteur
d'épargne de tout pays unissez-vous et
nous allons ensemble arracher le plus de
valeurs
possible au travail voilà c'est ça qui
s'est produit et pour éviter des effets
d'explosion politique et sociale le
système a mis en place donc seulement
ces filets de sécurité qui existait déjà
depuis les 30 glorieuses mais a a
maintenu en fait à flot
euh réussi en fait à avoir d'abord une
baisse des coûts de la consommation ce
qui a quand même permis pendant un temps
de stabiliser les choses le l'ouvrier
français ou le l'employés français parce
que les ouvriers en a plus beaucoup on
ont vu leur leur salaire stagner mais en
échange ils ont trouvé dans des
supermarchés des produits à bas coup de
main d'œuvre qui étaient fabriqués à
l'autre bout du monde donc ça a permis
un peu de maintenir leur niveau de vie
d'un autre côté beaucoup se sont
retrouvés sans emploi la croissance en
tendance sur le long terme en Europe et
on revient à ta problématique de
l'Europe à commencer à ralentir sur le
long terme et il n'y avait que
l'Allemagne finalement et quelques pays
du Nord qui arrivaient à tirer
leurépingle du jeu mais il faut bien
comprendre que que ce soit l'Allemagne
ou que ce soit le capitalisme français
qui fonctionne bien en général ils sont
axés sur l'exportation ils sont axés sur
et la production et la vente et
l'exportation dans des zones où la
croissance économique est plus forte et
dans des zones où la consommation est
plus forte et d'abord évidemment l'Asie
j'ouvre une petite parenthèse comme ça
tu peux savourer ton ver d'au château la
pompe
2023 merci à ta
santé tu sembles connaître les arcanes
du système financi
tu sembles connaître les les les les les
le système capitalistique est-ce que tu
mets des billes dedans pour essayer
est-ce que tu en croques c'est-àdire
avoir une intime connaissance d'un
système est-ce que tu as décidé d'en
croquer est-ce que tu es positionné sur
les marchés est-ce que tu fais de
l'anticipation des choses comme ça ou tu
fais comme beaucoup d'expert en Bitcoin
c'est il brassent du vent à la télé et
quand tu leur poses la question tu
roules en porche un château ah non j'ai
pas de por mais je connais très très
bien donc il y a des il y a des
sociologues qui vont pas sur le terrain
mais ils parlent il y a des
investisseurs qui parlent des marchés
mais ils sont pas sur les marchés euh
est-ce que toi tu es positionné est-ce
que tu as tu as tu as mis tes billes à
gauche à droite ou pas du tout alors je
vais te répondre mais ta question est
vraiment intéressante parce que elle
traduit le fait
euh qu'il y a enfin que que qu'on a
intégré ce ce ce schéma un peu américain
ou quelqu'un pèse ou ne pèse pas ou ou
presque la valeur d'un individu c'est sa
capacité à dégager de l'argent non
seulement sur c'est sa capacité à mettre
en pratique ce qu' préconce ouais non
mais c'est ça est-ce que tu manges ce
que tu
racontes alors ça m'est arrivé une ou
deux fois parce que j'étais je devais un
peu me refaire comme on dit j'avais
vraiment besoin d'argent donc j'ai j'ai
voilà j'ai utilisé des des on va dire
des anticipations entre guillemets qui
sont pas des anticipations d'ailleurs
assez c'est enfin si si si étonnante que
ça ça m'est arrivé une fois ou deux mais
comme ce n'est pas mon moteur c'est moi
c'est pas mon moteur de de de faire de
l'argent non je je j'occupe pas mon
temps à ça c'est pas quelque chose qui
me faire de l'argent pour ensuite se
donner les moyens de changer le monde
c'est bien aussi non bon j'ai peut-être
pas cette ambition je c'est vrai qu'il
il y a quelque chose d'ambivalent
peut-être dans dans dans ma ma personne
j'allais dire personnage mais je suis
pas un personnage mais dans ma personne
j'essaie de me voir un peu avec un peu
de recul on essaie tous d'avoir un peu
de recul sur soi c'est que finalement je
les gens de gauche pensent que je suis
de droite les gens de droite pensent que
je suis de gauche et l'autre
caractéristique que j'ai c'est que j'ai
eu des fonction de direction
euh je suis un peu un homme d'action
voilà et en même temps je fais des
bouquins et j'essaie de de de de
réfléchir donc je suis pas vraiment pour
les gens contemplatifs ou pour les
intellectuels plutôt un homme d'action
et euh pour euh les hommes d'action je
suis plutôt un contemplatif ou un
intellectuel donc je voilà moi je ça me
va très bien d'être dans dans cette
entre deux et euh de ne pas euh euh
finalement moi le le rapport que j'ai à
l'argent est assez simple je peux le
décrire c'est que je tu gagne
euh je je gagne j'ai toujours gagné
depuis assez longtemps dizaines de
milliers d'euros par mois à peu près net
brut euh brut pas net ça fait quoi 5000
balles entre 5 et 7000 oui entre 5 et
7000 par ailleurs
euh l'idée enfin mon rapport à l'argent
c'est de ne c'est de pas en avoir besoin
voilà j'ai jamais cherché à gagner de
l'argent mais quand pas quand tu en a
pas t'inquiète pas tu en as besoin mais
mais c'est précisément l'idée c'est
précisément l'idée de de ne pas enfin de
ne pas le prendre pour je sais pas moi
ça enfin je je je conçois parfaitement
que les gens se lance dans cette dans
une aventure enfin qui est d'accumuler
des des signes ou des symboles ou des
choses comme ça de d'une valeur en fait
qui est assez abstraite d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que tu penses des gens qui
parlent sans manger ce qu'il racontent
c'est-à-dire c'est dire je te prends
l'exemple des experts en Bitcoin ah oui
il y en a beaucoup qui donnent des des
conseils à gauche al il y en a certains
qui sont très très bons et qui mangent
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps ce qu'il
raconte mais la plupart la plupart ça
reste que du blabla c'estàd que quand tu
leur demandes bon est-ce que tu manges
ce que tu racontes ah bah non moi je
suis pas entrepreneur je suis pas dans
l'action je suis dans
l'analyse est-ce que est-ce que tu
connais des gens comme ça experts de
plateau télé bah qui ont jamais fait de
terrain qu'on jamais essayé de
d'infiltrer qui ont une vieille
expérience qui date d'années d'années
d'années de
décennie la rente quoi en fait ouais
même pas de la rente oui je dirais ouais
si peut-être la rente la rente passée ou
ou ou ou un vernis passé une le côté
lumineux d'un passé mais en fait ils
sont asbin ils connaissent pas la
réalité des choses ils vont jamais sur
le terrain et puis ils prêchent des
choses mais ils en ont les conséquences
c'est pas pour tu en connais des comme
ça oui mais mais ce qui est enfin je
prêche pas non plus ce ce ce ce culte du
terrain il y a différentes façons de de
de de comprendre le monde euh voilà
Marcel prou comprendre le monde sans
sans être sur le terrain a jamais été
sur le terrain je pense que ces livres
sont sont enfin disent beaucoup de
choses sur la sur la nature humaine moi
c'est pas trop mon mon style de
littérature mais je plutôt Joseph Kessel
que que Marcel prou mais enfin quand
quand on lit prou on se rend compte
qu'il y a quand même une une analyse
très assez assez puissante de de de la
manière dont fonctionnait la société
l'individu le mec est jamais sorti de
son de ses salons de ses salons
parisiens donc on peut on peut il y a de
multiples façons de de réfléchir et et
d'analyser la situation maintenant ce
que tu décris est vrai c'est-à-dire que
il y a l'archétype un peu du toutologue
avec des phrases toutes faites avec des
citations avec une espèce de petit
vernis c'est c'est assez français
finalement ce ce ce modèle non c'est pas
français non al ça doit exister dans
dans dans dans pas mal de pays mais on a
le attention ici on touche pas la France
tu prêches un convaincu un converti un
fanatique bon euh je te coupe encore t
prie tu parlais de variable d'ajustement
alors salarial alors clairement les les
salariés ils ont pleine plein la gueule
avec la la nouvelle idéologie
capitalistique dévoyé on est on est loin
des familistèes et on est loin de tout
ça tu es d'accord avec moi sûr là la
variable d'ajustement en terme de peuple
qu' des mauvaises décisions mauvaises
anticipation
c'est l'angle de courbure de l'Chine du
peuple qui permet de maintenir le
système c'est le fait que le peuple n'a
pas encore compris que faire de la
cavalerie budgétaire avec un état bah on
le paye dans 10 15 ans avec réduction
des services publics incapacité de faire
valoir notre parole à l'étranger parce
que économiquement parlant on a un
collier étrangleur de ceux qui
détiennent notre dette ou ceux qui
veulent nous faire
chanter comment ça se passe tu penses
que la variable d'ajustement du peuple
français va continuer à lui faire
courber les chines est-ce que tu as
confiance dans le peuple français est-ce
que ça veut dire quelque chose
d'ailleurs encore le peuple français si
on en croit Fourquet et d'autres
analyses analystes assez avisés il y a
une sorte d'archipélisation une sorte de
de dispersion façon puzle euh du peuple
français moi est-ce que c'est intuitif
purement intuitif est-ce que euh c'est
euh reste de de de lecture ou la
fréquentation de gens d'un autre âge
euh Charles pasqui des Jean-Pierre
Chevenement mais oui j'ai j'ai cette
j'ai cette impression très subjective
parce qu'on on parle de quelque chose de
subjectif un peuple c'est un affetio
sociétatiste comme disait romain c'est
c'est une c'est un sentiment qui va qui
va relier des gens qui partagent une
langue qui se reconnaissent dans un
gouvernement sur un territoire dans pas
un gouvernement mais un mode de
gouvernement en l'occurrence la
République et qui ont qui ont
cette cette impression d'avoir une
affinité ensemble bah je suis désolé
mais quand on voit un un alors ça peut
être tout à fait trivial mais un match
de la Coupe du Monde c'est quand même un
révélateur qui existe un affexo
sociétatiste Français peut-être même
d'ailleurs là où certains ne voudraient
pas ou pensent qu'il n'y a plus d'affeco
sociciétatiste français je je suis le
premier à à penser qu'il y a un grave
problème de de moi je préfère parler
d'assimilation d'intégration mais
d'assimilation des enfants et même des
petits enfants de d'une certaine
immigration c'est vrai mais quand il y a
un match de Coupe du Monde tu vois que
tout le monde sort le drapeau français
donc ça veut dire quelque chose quand il
y a un attentat le pays se sent
intégralement meurtri beaucoup plus que
si ça si ça ça si l'attentat survient
chez le voisin il y a et quand un pays
de la zone euro marque un but dans dans
une compétition internationale les gens
ne sortent pas leur drapeau leur drapeau
européen donc je pense que cette
affection sociétatiste même si c'est
rentré même si c'est une espèce de même
si c'est avec beaucoup de pudeur parce
que le patriotisme français est pudique
il a toujours été pudique c'est pas le
patriotisme américain oui ça existe les
Français sont conscients il y a
d'ailleurs une fierté blessée j'aime
beaucoup cet auteur Philippe diryarne
qui a écrit beaucoup de choses sur la
notion de prestige mais qui a bien
analysé aussi ce qui était finalement au
fond euh l'identité française et
Philippe diibarne dit il y a une tension
particulière en France c'est un pays
comme tout le monde sait enfin en tout
cas ce que les gens qui ont lu toville
savent que c'est le pays de la passion
de l'égalité il y a une folie de
l'égalité c'est le pays qui invente le
maître et talon voilà tout le monde doit
être sous une même ise parce que c'est
un un état qui va accoucher d'une nation
et d'un peuple et puis il y a ce côté
aussi d'ailleurs un peu mesquin un peu
jaloux on veut pas que le voisin et plus
et cetera et simultanément et pour la
même raison d'ailleurs logique c'est le
pays de où les gens cherchent à se
distinguer cherchent le prestige
cherchent l'honneur cherchent une forme
une forme de reconnaissance même très
symbolique et d'ailleurs parfois le
symbolique au détriment du réel ce qu'
avait compris Adolf Hitler il suffisait
de donner au Gaulois l'illusion que la
moitié de leur territoire était contrôlé
c'était la la zone libre pour pour qu'il
soit content finalement et ce qui était
ce qui était très malin de la part
d'Hitler parce que c'était c'est un
territoire le territoire est quand même
assez vaste il fallait immobiliser
beaucoup de troupe donc il y a quelque
chose comme ça dans la psychologie
française qui est la passion de
l'égalité et la passion de la
distinction tous les Français rêvent
d'avoir d'être président de quelque
chose ou d'avoir une décoration et en
même temps tous les Français ont cette
idée que personne voilà le le le plus
grand enfin dit Montaigne le le le plus
grand roi n'est jamais assi que sur son
cul donc ça c'est très très français et
Philippe dirbarn utilise la la fameuse
tirade du NON MERCI dans Cano de
bergorac pour dire la France c'est ça
c'est un peuple de citoyens qui aspirent
tous à être des aristocrates voilà et ça
c'est ça c'est vraiment très français
donc si tu pose la question est-ce qu'il
existe encore quelque chose comme la
France est-ce que cette idée elle est
morte ou pas non je pense qu'elle n'est
pas morte maintenant pardon j'ai fait
une grande digression à revenir à ta
question la variable d'ajustement à la à
ta variable d'ajustement euh on est dans
un paradoxe à nouveau parce que il me
rapport aux mauvaises décision prises
hein oui je crois que les Français sont
inquiets ils sont inquiet pour l'ordre
public ils sentent qu'on peut être une
dans une situation de bascule où l'ordre
public va céder et et où il va y avoir
le retour d'une vraiment d'une
violence d'une violence politique d'une
violence à grande échelle on l' s po
déjà non non c'est c'est à pas bruit le
venin le venin le venin oui le venin
politique dans la parole politique alors
la violence dans la parole et pas que
dans la parole hein 120 attaques au
couteau par jour le le propre de cette
violence les sources de ça oh c'était
c'est une c'est une donnée qui de 2017
et c'est à vérifier c'est à vérifier non
pas le le le chiffre lui-même j'en suis
sûr mais la la source est-ce que c'est
le ministère l'intérieur qui ressent ça
probablement parce qu'il y a que lui euh
qui doit qui doit avoir ces ces
données-là c'est pour 2017 ce qui est ce
qui me semble juste euh pas intéressant
non c'est c'est tout sauf intéressant
euh c'est qu'il y a ça exprime autre
chose cette violence exprime autre chose
qu'une simple violence euh euh disons de
de
euh une volonté de de de de voler ou de
s'approprier euh euh le bien d'autruie
et cetera il y a il y a il y a une sorte
de de rage là-dedans qui s'exprime il y
a une montée de violence dite gratuite
enfin c'est ça c'est c'est quand même
c'est quand même important des chiffres
pour la
Corse de non j'ai pas les chiffres pour
la Corse j'ai pas les chiffres pour la
Corse mais par contre j'ai été cet été
en Corse où ça euh je suis baladé
j'avais j'avais un bateau j'ai fait un
peu de de de cabotage mais c'est un
grand bateau tu veux tout savoir tout
savoir c'était euh océan 500 non non non
non de
C B à voile pas du tout du tout bah tu
penses que ce sera la première personne
à qui je raconterai non non je fais pas
d'évasion fiscale et et en l'occurrence
avec un copain on a loué un catamaran
j'ime plus c assez gros parce qu'on
était nombre un truc dans ce goû là
voilà un truc dans ce truc un vieux truc
un vieux truc mais mais c'était
bonfortable très confortable c'était un
peu un promè tourç permis au turi ou il
y avait un équipage non non non non moi
je l'ai pas mon pote était prof au
glenant donc il manœuvrait ça très très
bien il s navigué c'est un vrai Mar il s
navigué c'est un vrai mari il est
glénant non c'est magnifique magnifique
euh et c'estit de la Pêche on n pas fait
de pêche parce qu'on avait pas de matos
malheureusement j'aime beaucoup la
attention pas de pêche dans les parcs
autour de la Corse c'est bien ver Botton
et puis pas l'encre n'importe comment
bon j'essaie de te déconcentrer un petit
peu Contin continu non non mais ça
marchera pas parce que ce que je voulais
te dire c'est que cet été cet
été j'ai vu partout où je suis passé
dans les petits vill
cette idée que Yvan Gloria à T donc Ivan
c'est Ivan Colona et Ivan gloire à toi
et c'est incroyable parce que on voit
que la nature a horreur du vide comme il
y a plus de patriotisme français comme
il y a plus d'affection sociétati
français bah la nature d'une certaine
façon reprend ses droits parce que les
êtres humains c'est pas c'est pas le la
vie de tous les cors c'estàdire bahvan
ilvan GL c'est ah non non tu as raison
tu as raison mais c'est un phénomène
étonnant il faut nuancer mais c'est un
phénomène étonnant parce que VO alors il
y a des tas de corses qui sont persuadés
que Yvan Colona est innocent et cetera
mais mais le simple fait que cette
l'idée de son innocence soit propagé
comme une traînée de poudre et l'idée
qu'il soit un martyre désormais de la
Corse parce que tué par un djihadiste
dans sa prison ça ça montre que les
peuples ont besoin de martyr ils ont
besoin de sacré ils ont besoin de de de
se sentir appartenir à un collectif et
la nature encore une fois à horreur du
vide c'est c'est une démonstration
chimiquement pure que l'être humain qui
est un mammifère grégèire qui vit en
groupe qui vit sur un territoire qui
s'approprie un territoire et qui a
besoin de de d'être relié par cette
affection cstétatis si tu le fais
disparaître si tu prétends qu'il n'y a
plus d'identité nationale qu'il n'y a
plus de patriotisme d'une façon ou d'une
autre ce besoin il va se il va trouver
un moyen de s'exprimer ailleurs de sorte
que les Corses redeviennent corses les
Bretons viiennent bretons les Juifs
redeviennent juifs les musulmans
redeviennent musulmans et ainsi de suite
donc chacun se tourne vers ce qu'il peut
lui donner une identité et un sentiment
d'appartenance parce que tout simplement
en tant qu'être humain on ne peut pas se
passer de ce sentiment et le plus fascin
gilet jaune on peut dire ça comme ça oui
il y a c'est un peu l'identité de ceux
qui n'avaient pas d'identité c'était une
riche idée d'ailleurs que Sarkozi nous
impose le gilet jaune peu un peu mais ta
remarque est juste parce que finalement
c'était un peu c'est un peu l'identité
de ceux qui n'en avaient pas puisque que
la la surclasse internationale qui va
d'aéroport en aéroport les les fameux
anywhere de de goodart de l'anglais
goodart eux ils ont une sorte de de
prestige et d'appartenance collective
qui n'est plus nationale certes mais
tout de même ils se sentent appartenir
exactement et d'ailleurs dans les dans
les dans les quartiers dit sensibles ou
dit populaires certains appellent ça des
quartiers populaires autrement dit
quartiers pauvrees pas que il y a des
d'autres quartiers pauves là je parle
des banlieux où il y a des espèces de
ghto un peu refermés eu même et tout ça
beaucoup de trafic de stupéfiants là ce
qui est fascinant ça se voit à l'enu
cette loi de de l'impossibilité pour les
être humain de vivre en territoire sans
être dans un groupe et sans se sentir
appartenir à à un lieu finalement avoir
bah les gens de de de la Grande Borne se
tapent dessus contre les gens euh de la
de la cité d'à côté en fait spontanément
l'être humain va recréer un
microopatriotisme c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer ce que j'avais vu en Corse
on n sort pas en fait comme on ne sort
pas de la guerre on ne sort pas non plus
de ce besoin d'appartenance collec faut
pas comparer les Corses avec la Grande
Borne bah non mais attention on peut là
on peut plus comparer aujourd'hui parce
que tout est devient extrêmement
sensible en fait on peut pas penser sans
comparaison mais bien sûr qu'il y a
toujours des points qui invalident la
comparaison là il y a beaucoup de choses
qui n'ont rien à voir entre la Grande
Borne et les Corse mais il y a un point
commun c'est que ce sont c'est qu'il y a
le besoin de sécréter une appartenance
collective et de se sentir en tant
qu'individu relié à un groupe un groupe
qui donne une qui donne un prestige qui
donne une fierté et qui engage
d'ailleurs une forme de d'hormone
agressive ou de violence c'estàdire que
si on va chercher des noises au cors ils
seront là ils vont répondre si on
cherche des noises à la Grande Borne ils
seront là ils vont répondre et ainsi de
suite c'est toute la folie de l'Europe
l'Europe n c'est un affection ctatis
absolument abstrait et et sans aucun
sans aucun aucune aucune chair aucune
mémoire aucune aucune sensibilité et
donc personne ira se faire trouver la
peau pour défendre l'Europe l'Europe
c'est une abstraction en fait c'est une
idée c'est une idée c'est l'idée d'une
utopie qui n'est plus ni le trè Reich ni
l'Union des républiques socialistes
soviétiques qui est une sorte de
troisème utopie cette troisème utopie je
pense que c'est l'idée que on peut les
gens peuvent vivre sur un territoire
sans affection sociétatis donc sans se
faire la guerre sans avoir quelque chose
qui soit au-dessus de et qui qui toisent
l'individus et surtout c'est une c'est
une
utopie dangereuse parce que on est on
est dans le vide en quelque sorte on est
dans le vide on a démonétisé les nations
et on a rien d'autre à la place il sont
sympa les Corses ils sont fantastiques
ils sont adorables ils sont fantastiques
c'est une terre sublime où les gens tu
as déjà voyagé un petit peu en dehors de
la France un peu un peu combien de temps
je su pas un grand voyageur mais je tu
as voyagé où et combien de temps et par
quel
moyen tu as fait un club made War zazat
ou où tu as pris tes baskets un sac à
dos tu as appris trois mots euh du coin
pour
euh je je suis je encore une fois je
vais passer pour un un un centriste mais
ni l'un ni l'autre euh mon capitaine
c'est-à-dire que euh j'ai passé par
exemple une fois dans ma vie
pratiquement 2 mois en Égypte dans dans
une famille au Tamam euh la
la non mais je je suis pas arabophone
d'accord voilà et donc tu as passé de
mois sans apprendre un seul mot oh si
mais j'ai j'ai de vagues souvenirs allez
donne-mois-en non non non non là voilà
pas pas de euh j'ai donc j'ai me suis
baladé parce que dans l'école dans
l'école de commerce que je dirigeais
j'ai installé c'était où en Égypte au au
pardon merci au je quartier euh pas très
loin de mbaba tu connais mbaba quartier
assez populaire près de la place Taria
pas très loin mais pas tout à fait à
côté de la place derère non donc même je
me suis ok c'est ça je me suis baladé un
peu en Chine euh notamment dans le Yan
alors j'ai fait je suis pas resté très
longtemps mais j'ai fait beaucoup d'All
organisé par qui non c'est c'est c'est
j'ai installé une j'ai installé une une
succursale on peut dire ça comme ça une
antenne
de l'école de commerce que je dirigeais
euh à Kunming donc à la frontière enfin
dans le sud de la Chine la frontière
entre le Vietnam et la Chine et c'est un
c'est un un territoire magnifique
d'ailleurs qui est une zone grande zone
de tourisme pour les pour les Chinois et
donc j'ai Essé assez fréquemment les
Égyptiens ils t'ont renommé ils t'ont
donné un surnom ou pas euh
oui mais je vais pas le dire là parce
que pas c'est quoi ton surnom ton nom
ton prénom ton nouveau prénom bien les
Égyptiens
ils sont très sympas les Égyptiens mais
quel quel donné ex euh je non je je
dirais pas là parce que c'est pas c'est
un peu c'est un peu voilà fol clot on va
dire ça comme ça pourquoi le fol cl non
parce qu'en fait ce que j'avais pas
compris en réalité c'est que euh quand
on t'invite à à à manger à un moment tu
tu de toi-même tu dois dire STOP voilà
et moi je pensais que c poli ah bah tu
vois bien je je dis pas stop mais tu
vois bien qu'en fait je pensais que
c'était c'était au contraire poli euh de
manger tout ce qu'on me donnait mais on
m'a on m'a donné des des quantités
absolument astronomiques donc ça les ça
les a beaucoup fait rire en fait jusqu'à
ce que j'ai compris qu'en fait je
pouvais pas mon espérance de vie allait
vraiment euh euh si je si j'avalais tout
ce qu'il me proposait comme comme
calorie j'allais pas vivre très très
longtemps voilà non mais en fait c'est
un c'est les peuples qui ont beaucoup
souffert qui font ça en général ah bien
sûr bien sûr il y a un rapport à la
nourriture qui est euh qui est un peu
névrotique oui c'est vrai ça été de
balader un peu dans le sud de
l'Égypte non j'ai pas été en Haute
Égypte j'ai été beaucoup est-ce que tu
as en quelle année ça en
80 17 je dirais 97 98 est-ce qu'il y
avait des problèmes de migrant déjà à
l'époque
euh non pas à ma connaissance il y avait
pas de problème de migrant mais il y
avait déjà j'ai assisté quand même à des
à des arrestations très très musclées
des mabar des des des services ou les
espèces de K noir de ber noir et des des
grands manteau noir genre matrix
exactement et qui ont arrêté vraiment
c'était CIT très violent et là c'était
je me suis rendu compte aussi que le
monde occidental euh pour un pour un
arabe enfin pour un Égyptien pour un
Tunisien pour un Algérien et cetera ça
pouvait quand même enfin un Algérien non
mais dans beaucoup de ces pays
être aré au monde occidental ça pouvait
signifier quand même répression torture
et cetera ENF voà il y avait une sorte
d'inversion un peu des
codes dans le monde au Proche Orient
comment tu vois le phénomène de flux
migratoire comment tu vois la politique
européenne de gestion des flux
migratoires comment tu vois la Turquie
la gestion de des flux migratoires grâce
à la Turquie ou à cause de la Turquie
comment tu vois l'Europe face aux
fondamentaux qui se détraquent le climat
l'économie l'énergie les ressources
est-ce que les les chemins ou les routes
migratoires vont créer des soucis est-ce
que c'est une chance c'est pas une
chance pour toi est-ce que vu la
démographie européenne qui il stagne un
peu c'est peut-être bien pas bien tu
vois où je veux en venir bien sûr je
t'écoute alors
d'abord on oublie toujours et notamment
les gens qui critiquent on va dire la
mondialisation le capitalisme oublie
toujours que ces flux migratoires c'est
le complément de la libre circulation du
capital ou des ou des marchandises la
mondialisation postule par pardon ou
c'est des gens qui souffrent mais ça
change pas ça change pas le fait que le
modèle capitaliste pose comme principe
qu'il y a un marché mondial et que les
facteurs de production doivent circuler
donc l'argent doit circuler et bien les
services doivent circuler et là certains
disent Hal au feu et je pense qu'ils ont
en partie raison mais par contre ils ne
disent pas halte au feu lorsque le
facteur travail circule et le facteur
travail circule aussi pour le bon
plaisir du capital puisque grâce à ça on
sait bien l'armée de réserve les
salaires n'augmente pas beaucoup euh on
peut payer les gens avec un lance-pierre
et cetera et cetera ce que l'Europe
pratique à l'intérieur de l'Europe avec
les travailleurs détachés le pratique
aussi à l'extérieur il y a pas que
l'Europe d'ailleurs parce que la
Grande-Bretagne sortie de l'Europe
continue d'ailleurs à avoir beaucoup
d'immigration pour cette raison donc
c'est d'abord c'est je pense que être
euh favorable à la liberté de
circulation euh des des migrants et à
l'accueil des migrants c'est tout de
même euh un réflexe capitaliste enfin on
est on est c'est un signe de ralliment
au au capitalisme euh normalement les
gens les salariés les salariés les plus
modestes devraient être absolument
hostiles à cette libre circulation
disons du facteur travail entre
guillemets parce que le sujet c'est bien
sûr que ça devient un une une question
morale c'est-à-dire que critiquer
l'immigration c'est être dans le camp du
mal euh et tous les migrants sont
maintenant des gens qui fui non
seulement la misère la torture et cetera
et tous les migrants économiques
deviennent automatiquement des
demandeurs d'asile l'asile n'est pas une
mauvaise chose en tant que tel mais
l'asile comme les gens un peu près
informer le savent c'est c'était
vraiment réservé à très peu d'individus
dans la Constitution et dans nos
principes il s'agit de se battre pour la
liberté et ça correspondait à des
profils type solginiitine quoi là c'est
pas solginiitine là c'est des centaines
de milliers de gens l'asile climatique
dont on ferait pareil à leur place on
ferait exactement pareil à leur
placeasile climatique tu croit tu croit
pas
c'est un autre sujet oui j'y crois mais
il est pas alors je je vais répondre à
ta question je pense que les les
migrations à l'intérieur de l'Afrique
parce que la transition démographique
est pas terminé en Afrique vont d'abord
se dérouler à l'intérieur du continent
le plus simple pour les Africains dans
des zones qui deviennent répulsives pour
des raisons climatique ou parce que les
États s'écroulent les économies
s'écroulent et cetera et qui cherchent à
gagner un peu mieux leur vie ils vont
d'abord se se monterement à survivre ou
il cherche simplement à survivre oui
bien sûr et et là il y a une vision
quand même qui est assez faussée qu'on a
nous c'est qu'on se méfie beaucoup du
pourtour méditerranéen du sud de la
Méditerranée donc le Maghreb pour
l'essentiel puisque plus sont
francophones mais la transition
démographique est bien enfin a bien
démarré dans ces dans ces pays j'ai
regardé la la Tunisie par exemple les
gens ignorent que ça y est on est en
dessous du seuil de renouvellement des
générations en Tunisie la Tunisie c'est
un pays qui fait 1,9 enfants par femme
donc l'idée de l'Europe c'est à la fois
soit un ESP ir soit une crainte l'idée
qu'on va payer les retraites qu'on va
combler les trous démographiques parce
que on va faire venir des jeunes qui
vont bosser et financer nos retraites ou
qu'on va maintenir comme ça à flot notre
économie ou alors c'est une crainte
parce que on va être submergé c'est la
théorie du grand emplacement moi je
pense que ce qui est quand même fou dans
cette histoire totalement fou c'est et
là on se dit on se dit qu'il y a quelque
chose qui tourne vraiment par r c'est
que tu ne peux pas vouloir des choses
qui sont totalement contradictoires
autrement dit si tu penses que tu as
besoin de migrant pour financer tes
retraites le premier réflexe que j'ai
c'est pourquoi les mêmes qui disent mais
faites venir à nous des millions de
migrants les mêmes sont contre la
relance de la politique de natalité
c'est quand même très étrange voilà une
première contradiction qui c'est qui ces
gens-là bon ceux qui nous gouvernent euh
depuis il y a quelque chose qui
fonctionnait très bien en France c'est
la politique de natalité voilà elle a
été cassée par François Hollande réservé
au plus modeste donc en partie
effectivement à des populations qui sont
fraîchement arrivés qui ont pas encore
qui sont pas encore tout à fait dans le
dans le train démographique français
voilà on est à peu près à quoi 18
enfants par femme en France 1 un peu
plus entre 1,8 et 1,9 en partie grâce à
l'immigration si on retire l'effet
d'immigration je crois qu'on est à
1,67 il y a un seuil qui est
pratiquement irréversible c'est 1,5 et
là nous on est obsédé justement par la
question des migration c'est la question
que tu poses c'està direire bombe
démographique on sait que la transition
démographique elle est pas terminée qu'
a des part enfin le Sahel notamment pour
ce qui nous concerne qui a encore des
pays avec 4 5 enfants par femme ce que
faisait la Tunisie en fait il y a dans
les années 80 90 en Tunisie il y avait
qure ou 5 enfants par femme aujourd'hui
je rappelle en Tunisie il y a moins de
deux enfants par femme donc ces pays du
Sahel vont faire leur transition
démographique ils ont pas encore fait
leur transition démographique qu'est-ce
qui se passe quand il y a une explosion
de la démographie comme ça s'il y a non
seulement x 2 x 3 en terme de population
et donc avec potentiellement des
problèmes de de de subsistance aggravé
par le le tableau climatique et
deuxièmement il va y avoir aussi un
rajonnissement de la population
et en
fait je pense que c'est c'estes ces ces
migrations elles vont elles sont d'abord
attirer euh par la mise en place de
pompes aspirantes que sont cette
protection sociale qui est ouverte
totalement à tous et c'est une autre
contradiction très forte de vouloir
maintenir un système de protection
sociale très fort et de l'ouvrir de
manière universelle là c'est
automatiquement faire sauter la banque
puisque on sait qu'il y a de l'autre
côté de la Méditerranée des des
candidats par million qui peuvent venir
et et profiter de ces systèmes donc là
c'est une contradiction donc je pense
qu'il faut choisir son camp soit on dit
Bonz faites venir faites venir plein de
gens mais dans ce cas renoncer au
système de protection sociale ou alors
vous les défendre comme l' très
intelligemment compris les
socio-démocrates danois voulez défendre
votre système de protection sociale mais
dans ce cas il faut limiter les les ples
migratoires et en ce qui concerne tu me
posais la question sur la Turquie la
Turquie et même maintenant le Maroc ont
compris qu'il y a un chantage migratoire
qui peut facilement être exercé par ces
pays en disant moi j'ouvre les vannes si
j'ouvre les vannes tout de suite vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir donc
financez-moi faites des transfert
financier budgétaire et comme ça je vais
moi contrôler contrôler lesmigrant à
votre place ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs
pour la France fait la même chose pour
la Grande-Bretagne par exemple ce que
faisit Kaddafi non ce que faisait
Kaddafi bien sûr bien sûr mais en fait
donc cette question des des des flux
migratoires
elle est d'autant plus grave qu'on a en
même temps disons la volonté de dépasser
les état nations et donc on on on ne
croit plus nous-même dans notre modèle
assimilationiste donc au moment où on
renonce modèle assimilationniste on fait
venir beaucoup de gens dans une économie
qui tourne d'ailleurs vraiment parce que
l'immigration c'est pas c'est pas un
phénomène moral c'est ça l'erreur
l'erreur intellectuelle centrale de ce
problème de l'immigration c'est de
vouloir traiter l'immigration suivant
une grille morale bien ou mal en fait
l'immigration n'est ni bonne ni mauvaise
en tant que telle si ton économie est au
plein emploi
euh tu n'as pas de chômage du tout euh
et qu'au contraire tu es en temps
ça peut être intéressant pour toi de
faire venir des la force de travail qui
va
augmenter améliorer encore ta croissance
ta richesse ta production et cetera
quand tu vas taper les ressources chez
les copains que tu corroms les
gouvernements qui a sur place et que tu
t'en mets plein les fouilles tu parles
de la Russie là non la Chine la France
non ah bah oui enfin on n pas les seuls
à faire ça mais moins je pense
d'ailleurs que les autres mais mais bon
qui aime bien châtie bien donc on est
français on peut sut châtier c'est ça et
donc le quand tu vois ça est-ce que on a
aussi nous la France une obligation
morale c'est-à-dire que notre société
thermoindustriel alors peut-être moins
parce qu'on est la France on a un
système thermonucléaire donc on on aimet
moins de carbone puis on fait gaffe on
on envoie notre pollution que chez les
chinois mais est-ce queon a pas des des
une responsabilité morale par rapport au
réchauffement climatique quand tu vois
que certaines zones du monde avec un
taux d'humidité très important une
augmentation des températures ça devient
l'étal de se balader la journée est-ce
qu'on a pas aussi une responsabilité
face au monde nous les occidentaux les
les prêcheurs du capitalisme appelle ça
comme tu veux comment on fait pour
réagir comment on fait pour
euh ça se calme un peu comment on fait
pour tendre la main comment on fait pour
aussi essayer d'apuser les souffrances
qu'il y a chez les autres est-ce qu'on
coopère ou est-ce qu'on fait des murs je
discutais tu parlais d'anecdote je
discutais avec un copain un vieux vieux
vieux vieux en plus copain il me disait
très bien informé il me disait ils ne
savent pas encore où est-ce qu'ils vont
construire le
mur alors on fait quoi on construit des
murs alors que ça sert à rien surtout
nous c'est un peu compliqué avec la
Méditerranée on fait quoi non encore une
fois c'est c'est c'est c'est intéressant
la manière dont tu dont tu poses la
question parce que tu la poses sur un
angle moral de du rachat d'un péché
d'une detteun péché originel de
l'Occident sous forme d'émission de
carbone sous forme de prédation de
destruction des matières première de
colonisation et C est-ce qu'il faut
cette conduite introspective non je ne
pense pas je pense que
euh la colonisation est un phénomène par
exemple qui est très très mal compris la
colonisation c'est pas l'invention de
l'Occident l'esclavage c'est pas
l'invention de l'Occident ce sont des si
l'Occident a inventé quelque chose c'est
la décolonisation c'est la seule
civilisation qui a décidé euh de se
d'être décolonisé c'est la seule
civilisation qui a aboli l'esclavage
c'est pas donc l'Occident je veux bien
que l'Occident a commis des prédations à
une échelle apocalyptique pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait de l'esclavage un peu
partout entre tribus che l'esclavage est
un est un Universal humain l'esclavage
n'avait nait jamais C oui voilà
exactement exactement ce qui me
paraît frappant et intéressant c'est
vraiment cette idée
de du péché originel qu'on retrouve dans
dans le dans la dimension wi c'estàdire
on aurait c'est le fardeau de l'homme
blanc quoi autrement dit et et c'est et
ça et ça ça nous poursuit le fardeau de
l'homme blanc ça nous a obligé à
coloniser à aller entre guillemets
casser les pieds de ces de ces peuples
premiers ou des peuples qui voilà parce
que le phénomène de colonisation c'est
le décalage temporel la colonisation ça
c'est c'est quelque chose qui s'impose
même si tu ne le veux pas parce que tu
as des des sociétés qui peuvent
techniquement pas moralement mais
techniquement vivre à des époques
complètement différentes des siècles et
des siècles de différence et ça crée une
sorte d'appel d'air voilà et et je pense
que c'est le phénomène de la de la de la
colonisation on le voit comme une sorte
de une imposition violente et nous en
France on a cette idée de la
colonisation avec par exemple la guerre
d'Algérie la décolonisation très
violente de la guerre d'Algérie la
guerre d'Algérie c'était plutôt un
c'était plutôt une une une exception à
la règle de la colonisation française
euh la guerre des d'Algérie il y a eu un
transfert de population européenne et je
pense que la colonisation de peuplement
évidemment elle est très compliquée
ensuite à gérer parce qu'il y a des gens
qui viennent et qui s'instalent chez les
autres et qui prétendent être chez eux
donc au bout d'un moment ça devient ça
devient très difficile et ça a été très
difficile et très violent et tu vois on
retrouve ce problème avec l'immigration
l'immigration ça peut être un bénéfice
et moi je pense je suis pas fais pas
partie de ceux qui pensent que
l'immigration il y a une barrière
culturelle s'ils ont telle ou telle
religion on peut pas et cetera non mais
il y a des conditions pour que ça se
passe bien la condition c'est qu'il y a
une croissance économique forte donc ton
économie en a besoin et c'est vrai pour
toi mais c'est vrai aussi pour ceux qui
arrivent c'est important aussi d'avoir
disons énormément d'enfants indigènes
parce que l'assimilation ne peut se
faire que par les enfants c'est les
enfants qui font que les nouveaux venus
les enfants des nouveaux venus immigrés
vont se transformer en français c'est
parce que les nouveaux arrivants se
retrouvent dans des classes où il y a
beaucoup d'enfants français c'est les
enfants français qui vont les
transformer en en français donc résoudre
le problème problème de la baisse de la
natalité en faisant venir des palanqués
de gamins qui vont se retrouver entre
eux dans des ghos c'est une idée
complètement folle et la critique de la
colonisation de peuplement par exemple
l'Algérie c'està que les les Européens
disent bah on est chez nous on
s'installe chez vous et là ça serait
plus légitime en sens c'est qu'on prend
des populations qui vont se concentrer
rester entre elles et dire on fait pas
partie de votre société nous on veut
installer une contresociété et ça ça
serait bien donc pourquoi ça serait mal
dans un sens et bien dans un autre parce
qu'on en revient à cette idée de pécher
originel de l'Occident qui est une
vieille idée chrétienne on a croqué la
pomme et cetera et cetera donc pour
répondre à ta question je pense que
l'image qui me vient c'est celle du
Titanic c'està-dire que si d'aventure il
y avait ce ce une une catastrophe
planétaire clim sous forme climatique
par exemple et qu' des canaux de
sauvetage et que les pays du Nord soient
des canaux de sauvetage est-ce que faire
venir qu ou C ou six fois la proportion
des gens dans le Canau de sauvetage sur
le Canau de sauvetage pour que tout le
monde coule est-ce que ça servirait à
quelque chose non on coulerait aussi et
et et on les sauverait pas davantage les
pays du Sud aussi après le tropique du
Cancer et après le tropique dune bien
sûr bien sûr et je pense que les les les
les zones de haute et de basse pression
j'essaie d'expliquer à l'intérieur de
l'Afrique par exemple c'est sur le
continent africain et on le voit en
Tunisie par exemple le président
tunisien a des positions qu'on pourrait
qualifier de xénophobe ou d'extrême
droite il a un discours extrêmement
virulent contreant qui a amené
énormément de violence énormément de
violence énormément de violence on voit
que ces pays dit du Sud et notamment des
pays musulmans n'ont aucune forme de
pitié et aucune forme de compassion pour
des migrants que s'agiss des migrants
économi climatiqu c'eston surnom
égyptien tu diras pas tu fais de la
plongée bien essayé pas avec de
palqu moi je su un plongeur très amateur
je suis pas un pro de la plongé tu crois
en Dieu
oui c'estàdire
c'està-dire que tuas un ami
imaginaire non c'est pas un ami
imaginaire c'est
que ce qui me ce qui me fascine c'est le
problème de la conscience c'est-à-dire
que c'est pour c'est pas la question
c'est pourquoi il y a il y a y a il y a
il y a c'est pas pourquoi il y a quelque
chose plutôt que rien c'est pourquoi on
en est conscient pourquoi on a ce ce
regard cet œil ouvert sur le monde il
doit y avoir il doit y avoir une raison
à ça je ne sais pas si en revanche C
raison elle elle elle nous est
accessible peut-être que non mais il y a
une sorte
de il y a un code quoi il y a quelque
chose qui a a il y a un programme enfin
il y a quelque chose qui est qui est
quand même assez fascinant dans
l'organisation de l'univers et dans
notre dans notre organisation à nous
parce que tu arrives pas à
l'expliquer non fascinant d'abord parce
que j'en suis conscient alors est-ce que
ça veut dire que je me prends pour le
centre du monde non
mais
euh on ressent quand même une une idée
d'harmonie cette idée elle est elle
court dans toutes les civilisations
humaines
euh est-ce que c'est le mystère par
exemple de l'art est-ce que le fait de
de d'écouter une symphonie ou de voir
une une œuvre d'art qui a traversé les
siècles ça te renvoie à l'idée d'une
sorte
de d'ordre ou d'organisation de
l'univers et d'harmonie de l'univers
peut-être peut-être enfin en tout cas
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais douté qu'il y
avait quelque chose plutôt que rien en
fait qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
avait une raison pour laquelle on avait
ce ce cet œil ouvert sur l'univers tu
crois en quel
dieu tu vas à la messe non je vais pas à
la messe je vais pas à la messe et je je
j'ai plutôt tu fais le carême non non
non enfin moi je je suis pas du tout
contre les les rites il s'avère que je
je n'adhère pas à aucun de enfin aucune
religion connue je pratique aucune
religion connue mais c'est plutôt une
sorte
de d'intuition de l'organisation de
l'univers oui tu Fran Mac non on t'a
proposé on propose à beaucoup de gens
tirer les bouboules c'est
ça dans trêve de plaisanterie tu me
diras pas ton surnom en égyptien si tu
me donnes le tien je te donne le mien
alors non mais parce que le tien il est
il est il est disciible ou pas oui si tu
vas le dire oui alors le mien alors je
t'explique
vas-y le mien il m'a été donné parce que
je suis l'esclave de
paix d'accord et toi c'est parce que on
t'appelle poubelle de table c'est ça il
y a un côté comme ça ouis d'accord donc
c'est moins valorisant tu
vois chacun son karma tu as c'est pas
une histoire de karma c'est une histoire
de compréhension compréhension tu as été
un mariage égyptien non du tout non j'ai
raté quelque chose apparemment ah ouais
surtout dans le Sud extraordinaire mais
c'est c'est c'est un pays absolument
fascinant ouais les Égyptiens moi je
préfère les Égyptiens du Sud la Haute
Égypte la vrai ils sont ils sont plus
cool ils sont plus ils sont plus fun
j'étais dans une famille qui qui venait
de de copte qui venait de haut Égypte
donc des chrétiens donc des
chrétiens pas j'adore l'Égypte mais
c'est c'est facile on par une émission
spécial éypte revenons à notre énergie à
la Chine ouais et et à ce censé
anticiper les conneries faire des plans
à 30 ans il y a pas un commissaire au
Plan là comment il s'appelle
déjà comment comment il s'appelle déjà
d' moi ça me dis rien un centriste là
berou berou ah oui un un petit un petit
jeune ouais un petit jeune
ouais un startupper de la politique
ouais ouais ouis là là il y a un papier
du Times qui dit bon la Chine est en
train de sécuriser ses
approvisionnements en uranium euh ça va
mettre à peu près 5 ans à l'Europe pour
pouvoir reconstruire une chaîne
d'approvisionnement en dehors de
Moscou c'est quoi ça c'est une erreur
européenne c'est une erreur française de
pas avoir anticipé ça c'est euh mais moi
il me semble encore encore une fois au
risque de décevoir euh ceux qui
attendent des professions apocalyptiques
ou catastrophistes moi je pense que à
partir du moment où où la Russie a gagné
sa guerre contre l'Ukraine ça va être un
peu business as usual mais tu planes à
100000 toi non non je veux pas dire que
la Russie va nous vendre va nous
revendre son gaz comme s'il s'était rien
passé bon marché et cetera mais je pense
que d'abord la Russie va quand même
continuer à se méfier de la Chine et que
là était bien contente finalement de pas
se mettre complètement à dos la Chine
mais la politique d'un État est quandême
dans sa géographie je pense que la
Russie est quand même très inquiète de
ce qui peut arriver en Sibérie dans le
dans le voisin d'une puissance
aussi disons en pleine en plein boom
comme peut l'être la puissance chinoise
deuxièmement je pense que cette idée on
s'est fait un peu peur avec cette
démondialisation démondialisation il
peut y avoir les gens vont anticiper les
Chinois vont anticiper les Américains
vont anticiper et nous on va rester
comment en short et en tong non parce
que parce que tout de même si on moi je
je ferai la le distingo entre les
questions militaires stratégiques de
sécurité et les questions économiques si
on est dans le business et dans
l'économie si il faut les découpler les
les les Américains n'ont pas intérêt à
ruiner l'Europe ça va pas les intéresser
de ruiner l'Europe à quelle à quelle
échelle de
temps bah pour des raisons de sécurité
ça les intéresse ça les intéressait de
couper les zasis gaziers de de
l'Allemagne et ou ah non tu parles du
pipeline ça les intéressait bah ça les
intéressait donc écouté tu as écouté le
le l'ancien directeur de Stratford en
2015 ou en 2016 qui parle de ça c'est
non tu l'as vu non j'ai pas vu qu'est-ce
qu'il dit il dit quand même on va pas
savoir comment arriver à persuader les
Allemands de couper le cordon bé avec
les
la même chose résumé trivialement he h
oui c'est c'est c'est c'était la seule
possibilité qu'il y ait vraiment une une
indépendance un peu un peu stratégique
de l'Europe enfin la vague idée d'une
indépendance stratégique de l'Europe
c'est effectivement les matières
premières russes et euh et la la
technologie l'industrie allemande de
l'Europe de l'Ouest tu joues au risque
j'ai joué je joue plus depuis longtemps
mais ce qui ce qui m'a vraiment beaucoup
frappé c'est que j'ai lu le bouquin de
de Maurice Gourdeau montagne qui était
le le Cher pas de de Chirac à l'époque
où Chirac et Poutine étai il était pas à
la colle mais enfin quand même Poutine
avait été assez estomaqué que la que la
France tienne tête aux États-Unis dans
l'affaire de l'Irak et à un moment
Poutine ce que raconte Gour de montagne
je pense que c'est vrai dans son ses
mémoires lui dit que euh Poutine veut
faire savoir à Chirac qu'ils ont de beau
restes en matière de
mathématique de chercheurs et de
technologie militaire euh et que ils
sont très très intéressés euh à à monter
un partenariat avec l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne et la France là on est dans
les années 2003 2004 et je pense que là
quelque chose pouvait se se jouer avec
la Russie donc si ton idée c'est de dire
que la la Russie va pas passer
l'épongeou tourner la page c'est vrai
que l'énergie va être plus cher en
Europe en Europe c'est vrai est-ce que
pour autant les États-Unis et la Chine
vont cesser de commercer est-ce qu'on va
aller vers la démondialisation est-ce
que le plan de
dédollarisation de la Russie et de la
Chine va fonctionner comme ça à court
terme moi je ne le vous je le sens pas
trop comme ça mais je peux toujours me
tromper comment tu analyes les bricks
comment tu analyse l'Arabie Saoudite
alors je pense que les gens en ont un
peu marre quand même de
l'extraterritorialité de de de des lois
américaine que ça c'est quand même euh
c'est quand même poison pour tout le
monde
euh ça a été quand même gage de paix la
paxa Americana pendant des années
non fait l'avocat du diable oui tu tu
peux parce que ça a eu comme ça a eu des
ça a eu cet effet-là mais ça a eu
surtout cet effet-là paradoxalement
pendant la guerre froide
à partir du moment où les États-Unis
n'ont plus d'adversaires en face ils ne
se sont plus tellement tenus non plus
ils ont commencé un peu à faire
n'importe quoi et à et à propager le le
désordre et le chaos et à se transformer
vraiment en une puissance égémonique qui
ils onté la démocratie ça c'est ça et
les droits de l'homme et pour les écoles
pour les petites filles et c'est comme
ça qu'il rachètent ADS et c'est comme ça
qu'il détruisent l'Irak et c'est comme
ça et cetera et cetera ouais bien sûr
mais et cette histoire là ne casse pas
mes rêves c'est bientôt Noël on a pas
tous la chance d'avoir un ami
imaginaire tu veux ben je peux te donner
ses coordonnées si tu veux Père Noël non
de l'ami imaginaire l'ami
imaginaire c'est pas l'ami c'est c'est
plus c'est plus vraiment l'ami américain
en fait les États-Unis c'est vrai qu'ils
ont offert une sorte de
d'assurance d'assurance vie à la fois
militaire c'est la
sécurisation par exemple des routes
maritimes par la par la la NAVY
américaine dans le collier de perle
surtout dans le collier de perle
exactement mais enfin dans les dans les
d3ro aussi de de golf persique et tout
ça que ça ça se payait parce qu'il faut
toujours payer son service de
sécurité ils ont l'OT temp non c'est ça
c'est l'ut temp l'OT temp c'est le c'est
le vigile en fait de la de la
mondialisation ou ou le mafieux c'est un
peu la même chose c'est c'est il y a
j' j'ouvre une parenthèse en 2024 on va
faire une émission sur les religions ou
c'est pour ça que je suis un petit
peu je je sens je sens en tout cas tu es
prêt là tu es tout à fait prêt et vous
allez inviter toutes les c'estê
trrecuménique j'imagine comme
bah on va commencer par notre ami
François très bien je t'ai coupé il faut
il faut tout de suite viser viser haut
ou au P oua au pire on arrivera sur la
Lune
en tout cas on en était où sur l'ami
américain c'est ça l'ami américain le
mafieux le mafieux je pense qu'il a pris
un peu trop ses aises voilà il a pris un
peu trop ses aises il
a agi justement ce modèle de la
mondialisation c'est le modèle du bon
plaisir individuel vrai pour les
individus et pour les dirigeants et pour
chaque individu qui pense qu'il n'y a
rien au-dessus de lui les États-Unis se
sont comportés vraiment de manière
absolument absolument égoïste euh et
et ce qui est normal d'ailleurs parce
que plus aucun plus aucune force pouvait
pouvait les arrêter et donc des acteurs
comme la Russie et comme la Chine ce
sont dit c'est très inquiétant c'est
très inquiétant on veut pas qu'il nous
arrive ce qui est
arrivé à des entreprises qui se sont
fait complètement essorer on veut
pas beaucoup de pays se sont dit
commencer par l'Iran c'est quand même
très inquiétant d'être dans le
collimateur des États-Unis ils peuvent
pour un oui pour un non sur n'importe
quel prétexte détruire l'état et et et
créer le chaos et cetera donc tous ces
gens-là ont cherché des gages et pour
revenir à l'Arabie Saoudite euh oui
l'Arabie saoudite a veut pas mettre tous
ses œufs dans le même panier et se dit
les États-Unis on sait pas trop sur quel
pied danser si un jour je ne sais trop
quelle coalition au sein du Congrès se
retourne contre nous on va on va se
retrouver euh euh pied et pointliers ou
chassé par un coup d'État ou je ne sais
trop quoi donc la manière dont les
États-Unis ont lâché leurs alliés les
uns derrière les autres ont été de
défaite et défaite de défaite en défaite
pardon en plus ça a incité ces pays dans
un calcul absolument rationnel à se dire
ce sont pas des gens ce sont pas des
gens fiables ou des gens des gens
sérieux donc on va soit s'organiser
complètement de notre côté parce qu'on a
plus le choix soit au moins ne pas
mettre nous de U dans le même panier et
voir de fer au feu et sincèrement je
pense que ce que c'est ce que la France
aurait dû faire je pense que la la la la
la France n'est pas terminée n'est pas
fini ce plan européen c'est-à-dire ce
plan de de
remplacer des gouvernements par une zone
de libre
échange omnitolérante
ouverte aux migrants ouverte à tous les
vents de la mondialisation et sous
parapluie et sous protection militaire
américaine c'est très très imprudent oui
c'est plus qu'un prudent donc la France
là-dedans elle pourrait tout à fait
reprendre ses
billes la
comparaison avec l'Inde est peut-être
difficile parce que l'Inde maintenant
est un pays qui a une masse critique
mais la comparaison avec la Turquie à
mon avis tient la route la Turquie a un
PIB beaucoup plus petit que le nôtre a
pas une population beaucoup plus
importante que la nôtre et la Turquie
arrive à naviguerdon grosse inflation
oui la Turquie a une grosse inflation
mais la Turquie pour le coup sera pas
nécessairement coupé du gaz russe he
voilà donc elle a réussi à naviguer et à
défendre ses intérêts de
nation s intérêt ces intérêts d'État
dans C dans cet univers assez assez
chaotique école de commerce le sang de
l'économie c'est quoi le sent d'économie
c'est pas que le pétrole c'est l'énergie
c'est l'énergie en général oui il y en a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs sources
d'énergie et donc la Chine qui sécurise
ses approvisionnements en uranium qui
achète des mines qui passe des contrats
long TER logique et plus en plus plus
fou encore euh qui va nous fournir la
technologie de nos de nos centrales
derniers cris en plus si j'ai bien
compris de 4e génération il nous restera
quoi il nous restera à nous reprendre en
main il nous restera atterrir dans
le dans la dans la vraie vie enfin dans
le vrai monde peut-être qu'il fait c'est
c'est moins confortable que deser rie
dououillettes ça c'est encore une autre
question mais en tout cas pour le coup
je pense que la France c'est pas en
claquant des doigts ça va pas se faire
tout seul mais la France a des moyens de
se de se
redresser
qu d'abord un
état il y a toujours une une culture de
l'État
importante il y a une démographie aussi
1,8 même si c'est en partie dû à
l'immigration pas que on est au-dessus
de ce seuil fatidique de 1,5 on peut
reprendre notre démographie la Chine
c'est un des États du monde on parle
beaucoup de la Chine qui sécurise ses
approvisionnements en uranium et cetera
la Chine c'est un pays quand même qui
fait quoi zéro enfin moins de un enfant
par femme la démographie comme dit
l'autre c'est vraiment le destin
c'est-à-dire que ce qui est inscrit là
dans dans le destin de la Chine c'est
que demain la majorité des Chinois
seront des petits vieux et il y a pas je
vois pas euh les jeunes Chinois pousser
deux chaises roulantes de vieux chinois
on sait que la démographie c'est souvent
oublié mais c'est un des moteurs de
l'économie donc oui l'économie ça
fonctionne avec de l'énergie tu as tout
à fait raison mais l'économie ça
fonctionne aussi
avec un renouvellement des générations
et un moteur et une croissance
démographique détriment du Biotop pas
nécessairement pas nécessairement tu as
des exemples oui nucléaire c'est plutôt
pas mal d'économie pas au détriment du
Biotop je vois ce que tu je pensais que
tu fa allusion alors les Papou
l'économie Papou euh nuit à son Biotop
est-ce que l'économie des Mayas ouais
nuisait à leur Biotop qu'est-ce que ça a
donné à force de construire des
monuments avec de la chou de 18 cm
d'épaisseur sur tous leur monuments oui
et puis le et puis le maïs je crois que
c'était des trucs qui éta c'est des
cultures qui éta qui donc est-ce que
l'économie Abî les terres on peut on
peut avoir une économie un système
capitalistique durable dit durable dit
dit on essaie de survivre sans se
prendre le ciel sur la tête c'est
toujours ce qui s ce qui s'est passé
jusqu'à
présent s toujours pris le ciel sur la
tête à la fois et et on a toujours on
dit que les
civilisations pourrissent avant de
tomber et que l'homme c'est l'inverse
c'est que l'homme pourrit après sa mort
mais les les civilisations pourrissent
avant leur mort est-ce que tu sens un
pourrissement de nos
civilisation c'està dire que la la la
réponse est presque dans la question si
tu poses cette cette question elle était
impossible à poser même il y a 30 40 ans
elle était quand même assez bizarre
assez extrémiste et elle est plus
extrémiste parce qu'on a tous maintenant
dans la tête que la civilisation
occidentale est gagné par une sorte de
de dégoût d'elle-même en réalitétion de
forfaiture de oui oui oui et puis et
puis on parle de on parlait tout à
l'heure de comment de de de de
l'attitude à l'égard
des FL des flu migratoires mais c'est
pratiquement dans tous les domaines qui
a un comportementtit face à l'homme pas
au fu migratoire face à à l'idée qu'on
se fait d'humanité oui B et si tu as vu
des expulsions de migrants en Égypte il
les balance à la frontière il don une
petite bouteille d'eau et puis salut bon
pas tous non mais ça c'est d'un point de
vue ENF c'est aussi un point de vue très
judéo chrétien c'est
pas l'idée que que l'autre est un frère
c'est pas c'est pas un universel humain
pour le coup vraiment
mais je parlais je faisis allusion à la
civilisation occidentale moi je je
dirais deux choses je dirais queon a oui
cette conscience aujourd'hui en
Occident d'être sur une phase de
déclinante parce que on on nattend ce
qui faisait la force de l'Occident c'est
le c'est un peu
l'idée de du prophétisme qui qui est
commune aux juifes et aux chrétiens
c'est-à-dire d'attendre quelque chose de
l'avenir et de d'être capable d'une
forme de
d'optimistme le défaut des civilisations
occidentales c'est qu'elles sont assez
instables mais leur force c'est quand
même d'espérer quelque chose de l'avenir
et cette idée je par même pas du mythe
du progrès à la mode Auguste conte et
cetera mais juste simplement le fait de
se projeter sur l'avenir ce qui est
vraiment enfin ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs
dans le dans le fait de faire des
enfants
ce qu'on voit dans le fait d'investir le
taux d'investissement ce qu'on voit dans
le fait de transmettre de former les
jeunes générations l'idée que quelque
chose voilà va nous succéder et que
demain peut-être meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
cette idée-là elle est effectivement
attaqué à la racine je pense qu'elle est
attaqué à la racine pour revenir au
point de départ sur cette idée qu'il a
rien auudessus de l'individu l'individu
et le début et et la fin de lui-même
finalement dans ce modèle d'économie euh
pur et par enfin de de de modèle de
néoclassique qui est aussi le modèle
68art l'individu est sa propre fin en
quelque sorte et là il y a quelque chose
de très déprimant là-dedans on a
l'impression que il y aura rien après
nous donc d'une certaine façon le seul
le
seul mouvement le seul mouvement enfin
le le le comment on pourrait dire le
seul courant de pensée qui verbalise et
qui rend conscient ce dégoût de soi des
Occidentaux c'est le wisme par exemple
mais en dehors du wokisme il y a de
multiples expressions de cette espèce de
de fatigue d'être soi donc oui on a
cette impression qu'on est un peu à la
fin de l'Empire romain qu'on ne croit
plus dans nos dans nos modèles et que on
on est fatigué d'être d'être ce que nous
sommes en fait de de porter pourquoi tu
juges entre guillemets le wokisme comme
ça ah ben c'est c'est moi je ne juge pas
le wisme j'écoute ce que le wisme dit il
dit quoi le wisme dit
qu'estce que j'entends
oui d'abord les wisme comme tu sais les
W refusent de d'être appelés eux-même W
enfin c'est on j' sait rien du tout à
l'origine c'est eux qui ont forgé ce
terme et maintenant il le il le ils le
rejettent ce que disent les wok c'est
que tous les péchés du monde viennent du
mal blanc occidental hétérosexuel du
patriarcat et cetera et cetera en fait
c'est la euh
la conscience enfin aucune
civilisation ne peut fonctionner sans
avoir une sorte de de confiance en soi
de confiance dans ses dans son dans son
propre modèle dans ses propres valeurs
le wisme c'est l'expression de la
détestation de soi par l'Occident à
l'intérieur de l'Occident l'Occident se
se rejette lui-même al bon c'est pas la
première fois qu'il le fait mais c'est
c'est c'était déjà le le du bon sauvage
de vouloir penser qu'il y avait que nous
étions dans la faute et dans le péché et
qu'en dehors du monde occidental il y
avait un être humain qui était
euh à l'abri de toute de toute
flétrissure mais désormais nous pensons
que la pollution les crises économiques
les totalitarismes l'esclavage la
colonisation et cetera tout et les
guerres
euh ça vient du monde occidental si
l'Occident se liquide lui-même disparaît
et bien voilà on va sauver le monde en
quelque sorte c'est aussi pour ça qu' a
ce rapport au migrant c'est que le
migrant c'est un peu le le celui qui va
racheter les péchés du monde et comme
nous avons beaucoup pêché alors nous
polluons beaucoup nous détruisons le
monde nous prenons les matières
premières du monde en fait la France a
jamais aussi peu piquer les matières
premières de l'Afrique alors que la
Russie et la Chine s'en par et font main
basse comme jamais
mais jamais alors moins on pique les
matières premières de l'Afrique et plus
on s'accable de piquer les matières
premières de l'Afrique et plus on laisse
les autres le faire à notre place tout
en ns accusant toujours de le faire ça
c'est absolument fascinant mais si tu
avais une chose positive à dire sur les
W
h c'est toujours bon de penser contre
soi
voilà question internet bonsoir l'équipe
demandez à Guillaume qu'il vous parle de
son dernier rapport avec clarcom et de
l'association France souveraine issue de
la revue de la revue Front
populaire tu veux t'exprimer tu veux pas
t'exprimer c'est en cours c'est pas en
cours oui non c'est en cours et puis je
suis un peu jugé parti dans l'histoire
donc j'en dirai pas grandchose si ce
n'est que France souveraine c'est vrai
que c'est une émanation de la revue de
Michel honfry Front populaire que je
pense beaucoup de gens connaissent
maintenant et que Front populaire ni
France souveraine qui a rassemblé au
départ les les lecteurs et les abonnés
de Front populaire n'a d'objectif ou
d'intention politique ni à se présenter
à des élections ni d'ailleurs à avoir un
positionnement qu'on pourrait ranger
dans une case droite gauche centre
extrême et cetera le propos de Michel
hfrey avec la revue de Front populaire
c'était de rassembler les souverainistes
de gauche de droite du Centre des
extrêmes de nulle part et d'ailleurs
donc bon voilà je pense que
l'arcom je fais confiance à l'arcom et à
cette autorité administrative pour euh
pour voilà ne pas me compter comme étant
un un représentant de telle ou telle
chapelle politique en fait il vraiment
al je je peux dire beaucoup de bêtises
comme tout le monde mais euh mais en
tout cas je ne défends pas une chapelle
ou un camp en particulier d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant on peut peut-être
faire une incis sur cette notion de
souverainisme moi j'ai pas trop cette
expression mais en tout cas de
souveraineté pour moi la souveraineté
c'est normalement un bien commun on
parlait de bien commun tout à l'heure ou
d'intérêt général ça devrait les gens de
gauche comme de droite devrai se
réclamer de la souveraineté après tout
la souveraineté c'est ce qui nous réunit
c'est les institutions du 4 octobre 58
c'est l'article 3 de la Constitution
c'est vraiment la pierre de touche la
souveraineté c'est le synonyme de
démocratie c'est la nation euh qui se
qui se gouverne elle-même c'est rien
d'autre que ça la souveraineté donc la
souveraineté les sou verainiste ne
devrait pas être un parti politique ou
être une chapelle en quelque sorte et
tous les partis en démocratie en
république devrai être souverainiste
voilà alors il s'avère que quand on
regarde prenons juste l'histoire de la
République
rapidement de 1789 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il y a toujours eu dans l'histoire de
notre République des gens pour contester
le régime républicain il y a eu des
monarchistes peut-être jusqu'en
1877 puis ensuite il y a eu le courant
socialiste marxiste
par royalisme était avait quasiment
disparu voilà il était un peu
folklorique dans les années 20 300 mais
il a disparu pratiquement et ensuite il
y a eu jusque peut-être en 1989 en 1991
un courant qui voulait voilà le le
courant communiste le courant socialiste
enfin tous les courants possibles et
imaginables de l'extrême gauche
révolutionnaire qui voulaient la
dictature du prolétariat qui voulait
jeter à bas la république bourgeoise on
peut dire c'était une contestation de
cette notion de souveraineté donc vois
la la la la monarchie l'idée monarchique
contestait la notion de souveraineté
républicaine et le marxisme contestait
la notion de souverainé républicaine et
là on se dit bon bah c'est fini 1989
1991 il n'y a plus de de combattants en
quelque sorte et la République a
définitivement gagné où l'idée de
démocratie est définitivement gagné
c'est raté c'est raté parce que
justement le courant des européistes
cette idée de vouloir fabriquer une
sorte d'état européen c'est précisément
de porter atteinte
à la souveraineté nationale et populaire
l'idée de la l'idée de l'Europe la
construction de l'Europe c'est vraiment
un dépassement de la démocratie et c'est
ça que que moi j'ai démissionné de Fran
souveraine mais Fran souveraine n'était
pas un parti c'est une sorte de San qui
réfléchissait à comment cette idée
cardinale et clé dans le système
républicain démocratique c'est la
souveraineté nationale et populaire
était en train d'être remise en cause
lentement mais sûrement avec une idée
justement de management avec une idée
que que on allait plus avoir une
démocratie politique on allait avoir une
sorte de gouvernance d'entreprise à
l'échelle
européenne en quelque sorte et que
finalement les autorités avec la
souveraineté européenne nous préparaient
une sorte de fusion acquisition c'est ni
plus ni moins une fusaque en réalité
entre des entre des pays avec l'idée que
c'est le marché mondial c'est qu'on doit
on doit régir le tout non plus en
fonction d'une majorité de suffrage
exprimé mais on doit régir le tout de
manière quasiment scientifique ou
mathématique à partir de lois
d'économie pour que ça soit conforme au
au au besoins du marché mondial en fait
c'est ça la construction européenne
question Internet les 20 alors on
vérifiera les chiffres plus tard
maintenant les alors question de
ciselons 20 % comment je dis bonsoir
cisel les 20 % les plus riches de la
planète monopolisent plus de 94 % des
richesses du monde c'est de la
détestation de soit c'est
judéochrétiennes euh non mais ces 20 % à
mon avis sont de moins enfin ne sont
plus alors qu'il est que des Occidentaux
déjà pour commencer et je pense que
c'est
un ce n'est
pas comment cet écartement des revenus
liés à la mondialisation c'est-à-dire
lié à cette utopie de faire disparaître
les démocratie au profit d'une sorte de
de de pilotage automatique via le marché
mondial et la bonne gouvernance et le
management et une sorte de science qui
dit faites du marketing fait de la
communication manipuler les peuples
comme C manipuler les peuples comme ça
et cetera et et il y aura un pilotage
automatique et ça sera une optimisation
du contrainte de la sous contrainte de
la gouvernance laquelle gouvernance va
fonctionner au profit des plus riches
bah ça c'est pas
exactement notre régime politique la la
l'Occident ne croit pas euh au à la
mondialisation capitaliste c'est un
c'est un dévoiement euh de de du modèle
occidental je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
SISEL mais ça remarque ça consiste à
dire que les Occidentaux sont plus
riches où est-ce que ça consiste à dire
il faut lui poser la question euh qu'il
y a un dévoiement ou une corruption de
des démocraties occidental avec un
écartement des revenus et une hyper
concentration des revenus et là c'est
vrai qu'on passe d'une idée à l'autre
c'est deux idées distinctes à
l'intérieur de toutes les démocraties
occidentales maintenant il y a une une
hyper concentration des revenus et une
explosion façon puse des des classes
moyennes qui était quand même le Baris
centre des démocraties et de l'autre
côté on continue à avoir une
concentration des richesses dans les
pays occidentaux mais c'est pas
exactement la même chose je pense que
s'il y a une concentration des richesse
parler dans les pays occidentaux c'est
d'abord parce que jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à la mondialisation donc c'est
quand même assez récent ce sont les pays
occidentaux qui étent les plus
productifs tu joues au tennis non enfin
si mais tennisman du comment
analysez-vous les très mauvaises al
question de Anne comment analysez-vous
la très mauvaise situation économique de
la Grande-Bretagne brexit
pointinrogation ok
euh bon très mauvaise situation est-ce
qu'elle est beaucoup plus catastrophique
que les pays de la zone euro il faudrait
enfin que les pays de la zone euro que
les pays de l'Union européenne tout
court ça mériterait d'être d'être
vérifié je pense que la Grande-Bretagne
n'est pas sortie de ce modèle de
mondialisation qui est un modèle où je
répète l'idée une idée assez simple le
capitalisme ne veut plus de risque
concentre des revenus et veut jouer à
risque version économique à l'échelle à
l'échelle planétaire au détriment des
classes moyennes donc oui c'est c'est
quelque chose qui qui est pas qui est
pas très stable qui fonctionne pas bien
donc la Grande-Bretagne elle est sortie
de l'Union européenne mais elle continue
exactement la même politique de
mondialisation qui ne fonctionne pas qui
est pas équilibré est-ce que tu as un
sujet que tu souhaiterais aborder avec
nous
hm je réfléchis peut-être qu'on peut
revenir un instant sur cette histoire de
Bruno Lemer oui c'est fascinant Bruno
Lemer bah voilà tu cherchais un ami
invisible lui il est c'est un c'est
c'est je sais pas euh si Bruno Le Maire
est il peut m'inspirer euh quoi que ce
soit l'homme qui voulait mettre à genou
l'économie russe c'est ça non
l'homme qui nous parle
d'inflation ouais non si si avec
Emmanuel Macron peut-être comment il
s'appelle notre ministre des Affaires
étrangères ou not comment tu sais le
ministre actuel des Affaires étrangères
euh comment s'appelle-t-il j'ai un j'ai
un trop de mémoire là alors Emmanuel
Macron non mais il s'appelle comment le
ministre d' affaires étrangères on verra
c'est pas le Dron non le Dron non le
Drillon c'était avant euh attends il va
me revenir enfin ça va me ça va me revir
tout alors c'est peut-être une femme non
c'est peutêtre pas une femme c'est
Colona oui c'est Catherine Colona
exactement mais tu vois c'est
intéressant que euh que je que j'ai pas
le nom tout de suite parce que ils sont
absolument interchangeables et qu'en
fait à part Emmanuel Macron c'est une de
ses caractéristiques euh voilà les les
gens qu' qu'il placent enfin j'exagère
un peu parce que je pense que il y a
quand même quelques ministres dit
politiques c'estàdire qui ont qui ont
quand même des ambitions personnelles
euh sont assez affichés enfin pas pas ou
alors il les cach serait très mal Gérald
armanin Gabriel Atal et cetera et que
pour la plupart le reste des ministres
sont des gens complètement
interchangeables entre les deux tu
choisirais
qui o j'ai de choisir aucun des deux
voilà c'est réglé non aucun des deux euh
comment tu vois l'élection 2027 ça se
passe bien pas bien plutôt centre droite
gauche comment ça se
passe Marine Le Pen mon avis est plutôt
sur les starting blocks là elle est
plutôt sur les starting blocks
euh parce que le enfin la bonne
gouvernance l'idée de mélanger on en a
on a malheureusement on a on a parlé que
de l'aspect économique des choses avec
le système capitaliste libre marché tout
privatiser privatiser euh les pertes
enfin rendre nationaliser les pertes et
privatiser les gains et tout ça et cette
idée de de bonne gouvernance capitaliste
avec construisons l'Europe qui protège
les marchés euh contre l'intérêt des
salariés on a parler de ça mais on n pas
vu que c'était quand même très connecté
à une vision très très extrême des
droits de l'homme quand même on n' pas
bouclé cette affaire mais c'est on on
établit rarement le lien qu'il y a entre
un état finalement assez peu répressif
le gouvernement des juges on va dire ça
comme ça l'État de droit donc vraiment
le droit qui qui qui neutralise un peu
la la la le côté régalien ou répressif
ou punitif de l'État et ce ce ce modèle
ce mod économique pourquoi il y a ce
lien entre les deux parce qu'au cœur du
sujet au cœur du dispositif il y a le
bon plaisir individuel de même qu'on
fait on peut faire du du business sans
entrave de même qu'on peut se déplacer
être dans nimp enfin comme on veut aller
s'installer dans n'importe quel pays les
juges estiment qui sont-ils pour juger
d'autres individus et pour et pour les
mettre en prison et pour restreindre le
leur liberté donc le système est un peu
est un peu bouclé comme ça et donc moi
je pense que le système il arrive à bout
de course c'est-à-dire que cette bonne
gouvernance
elle elle elle fait erreur système elle
bug alors là elle a buggé sur la la la
guerre en Ukraine avec des effets de
bord évidment très grave sur l'inflation
l'énergie et cetera les Médi les médias
ils ont traité il trait correctement le
sujet de la guerre en Ukraine de la
guerre en Ukraine ou de la guerre
israëlpestinienne ou de la guerre au
Nigéria ou de la guerre au y au TIGR en
Éthiopie ouais non bah non non Congo euh
non il traite pas enfin on a une vision
qui est très très très parcellaire du
monde d'ailleurs cette représentation de
la mondialisation c'est toujours les
mêmes pays c'est une sorte de
couche oui c'est ça c'est une fine
pellicule les question des États-Unis de
la Chine de l'Union européenne vaguement
de quelques émergents et voilà prenons
la guerre
Éthiopie avec le Tigré là l'éritré
500000 morts en 2 voilà personne n'en a
entendu parler donc pour répondre à ta
question non je pense qu'il a pas il
suffit d'ailleurs de regarder les médias
anglo-saxons les médias britanniques tu
rends compte qu'il y a tout un continent
complètement oublié qui est gigantesque
enfin plus d'un milliard d'habitants
tout ce monde Lafin Indo pakistanais il
s passe des choses c'est très important
c'est très intéressant en France il y a
pas de son pas d'image voilà par exemple
mais on pourrait multiplier les exemples
donc oui on on a une une représentation
du monde qui est finalement assez
limitée et les médias ont des prismes
qui qui sont très très étroits sur cette
guerre en Ukraine moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'on on a on sent un
peu la perte euh du point de vue
français c'est-à-dire que on a des
partisans de Joe Biden et des Ukrainiens
et on a des partisans de Poutine parce
que Poutine va nous venger des W je ne
sais pas trop quoi et de l'autre côté on
a Joe Biden et Zelenski qui va défendre
la démocratie et les droits de l'homme
non seulement c'est une vision
extrêmement maniquenne mais surtout nous
Français nous sommes sommés en quelque
sorte de de prendre parti c'estàd que la
position consistant à dire écoutez c'est
une tragédie les les deux parties comme
dans la question Israël ou palestinien
d'ailleurs euh c'est pas les bons contre
les méchants c'est pas les Indiens
contre les cowboy ça ressemble plus à
une tragédie grec où les acteurs de ce
de de de ce conflit euh dans les deux
cas vraiment sanglants ont de bonnes
raisons de se battre d'ailleurs et on
serait à leur place on se battrait aussi
c'est un discours inaudible absolument
inudible il faut que à la mode
américaine tout soit restitué en bien et
méchant il a se bre il y a se battre et
puis y aller boucher le Hamas
oui bien sûr qu'il y a des qu' a des
bouché mais mais le problème de
ces de ces bouchés c'est que c'est que
ce sont les bouchés ne sont pas toujours
des imbéciles c'est c'est le il y a pas
ça nous révulse donc on a
l'impression que l'inhumanité la cruauté
le sadisme poussé à un certain niveau
c'est forcément l'expression d'une
bestialité ou d'une bêtise est-ce que la
réponse dans le cas du Hamas
malheureusement j'ai je crains que cette
cette horreur absolue du 7 octobre c'est
quelque chose qui a été pensé
méticuleusement pensé méticuleusement
exécuté d'ailleurs est-ce que la réponse
israélienne ne va pas provoquer une
arithmétique de la rébellion dramatique
pour la région et dramatique pour le
monde est-ce que la la réponse
israélienne
euh bah ça fait des gamins qui se font
écraser sous les décombres ça fait des
des des femmes et des enfants et des
personnes
âgées ravagé est-ce que les
répercussions de cette réponse ne va pas
plus être délétaire qu'autre
chose avec la distance qu'on a nous
parce qu'on est pas partie prenante
directement oui c'est ce qu'on c'est ce
qu'on se dit et on sait bien
que quand on fait des dégâts collatéraux
on prépare on prépare des ennemis quoi
c'est sûr c'est c'est un c'est une une
bande annonce c'est c'est un plan enfin
le bombardement des civils à Gaza c'est
un plan de communication pour pour le
Hamas ou pour ce qui viendra après le
Hamas qui peut être pire que le Hamas
fantastique on est on est d'accord
là-dessus mais du point de vue des
Israéliens je suis pas certain d'abord
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'autres issus la
vengeance je dirais pas que c'est la
vengeance je pense qu'il y a une
dimension disproportionnée dans dans la
dans la réaction pas sur le plan moral
mais sur le plan simplement de de du
bodyc comme dis angl-saxon mais surtout
il y a pour eux
cette cette idée qu'il faut vraiment
qu'il marque les esprits qui frappent un
grand coup pour avoir un effet dissuasif
que s'ils ne font pas ça non seulement
la Leon la leçon va pas être va pas être
retenue et puis surtout les les
capacités opérationnel en face seront
pas détruites donc pour eux il y a pas
tellement de choix en plus je pense que
les Israéliens euh sont dans cette
optique il y a très longtemps qu'il
enfin c'est la phrase de Gold la mer
hein les les les Juifs al je pense que
ça s'applique davantage aux Israéliens
d'ailleurs mais ça la formule originale
de de goldam mer c'est les Juifs
préfèrent désormais et préféreront à
l'avenir euh les euh les reproches au
aux condoléances c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
il y a vraiment un engramé euh chez les
Israéliens l'idée que euh quand les
Juifs d'Europe se sont fait assassiner
pers person n'a bougé et ça n'a
intéressé personne et quand on a proposé
à Roosevelt de bombarder les voies
ferrées il a dit je fais pas les Guer
des Juifs voilà et ça ils l'ont gardé en
tête et donc ils sont dit bon le monde
entier va nous détester mais de toute
façon il nous déteste déjà et de toute
façon on a déjà failli passer à la
casserole une fois donc on repassera pas
deux fois la casserole là où ça devient
une vér là où je peux comprendre aussi
ce ce point de vue israélien c'est
qu'effectivement avec le recul qu'on a
nous on dit mais attendez les gars vous
êtes justement en train de creuser votre
propre tomble et c'est la la la la la
force prémonitoire de la conférence de
presse du du général de Gaulle après la
guerre de 67 de dire mais ce que vous
avez fait est incroyable vous avez
réussi euh d'abord vous avez batti un
état à la surur de votre front vous avez
et vous avez réussi finalement à vous
bonant malant à vous faire accepter si
vous allez plus loin vous allez être
rejeté et devenir complètement légitime
pour les Israéliens ils pensent qu'ils
sont de toute façon dès le départ
illégitimes que les Arabes ont refusé de
faire la paix qui refuseront toujours de
faire la paix donc la seule solution
c'est de leur imposer un rapport de
force et la seule solution on l'a vu en
S Jordanie c'est de grignoter de
grignoter et cetera moi je je crois
aussi euh que la la on peut tout faire
avec des baayonnettes dit bonapar sauf
resters dessus quoi en fait là ils vont
il va y avoir une administration
militaire israélienne à Gaza combien de
temps ça va durer quels effets ça va
avoir sur la population et sur la
sécurité d'Israël grand point
d'interrogation et au-delà de toutes ces
considérations il y a quand même une une
bombe à retardement
démographique si on considère que Gaza
laass Jordanie et les Arabes israéliens
au total ça fait quoi ça fait 6 7
millions de personnes il y a 6 7
millions de Juifs en face les uns et les
autres ont pas la même démographie si on
ajoute qu'à l'intérieur de la population
israélienne il y a en plus une minorité
croissante de de de fanatiques religieux
qui se reproduisent vitesse grand V tout
ça c'est assez inquiétant pour la
stabilité de long terme de l'État
d'Israël donc mon diagnostic comme je
vois pas de catastrophe après enfin là
je pense que les choses vont business je
disais business as usual c'est-à-dire
que je vois pas la démondialisation et
une rupture totale entre les États-Unis
et la Chine il y a quand même beaucoup
d'intérêts économique croisés et un
moment tout le monde va reprendre les
activités commerciales
classiques de la même façon je pense que
les Israéliens vont ement l'emporter il
a une telle disproportion de force donc
ils vont leur mettre une pilée et je
pense que business as usual c'est-à-dire
l'Arabie Saoudite même si l'Arabie
saoudite a envie de pas mettre tous ces
même panier et quand même de faire des
risettes à la Russie et à la Chine ça
veut pas dire que l'Arabie Saoudite va
pas avoir intérêt avec les technologies
militaires israéliennes avec l'aide de
qui voudra l'aider voilà trouver un
allié contre contre l'Iran parce qu'à
mon avis l'Arabie Saoudite est quand
même beaucoup plus inquiète par l'Iran
bien sûr que que par Israël donc la
plupart des pays arabes vont moi je
pense que le véritable danger c'est la
bombe démographique pour l'avenir sur le
territoire disons Israël plus 6 Jordanie
plus Gaza c'est ça qui et à l'intérieur
d'Israël c'est ça qui est dangereux pour
Israël les États arabes attention les
États arabes il faut peut-être découpler
les gouvernements arabes des populations
arabes justement qui sont pas tout à
fait alignés sur leur gouvernement mais
enfin les gouvernements arabes moi je
pense ont accepté Israël comme un fait
accompli et et je les vois pas faire la
guerre à Israël ou monter des coalitions
à court terme voilà moi je pense que
Israël a 15 ou 20 ans devant et
aujourd'hui l'opinion mondiale est à
cran et c'est normal mais le temps va
passer et c'est le calcul aussi des
israélien Israël reconnaît la cour pén
internationale ou pas je crois que non
mais tu le sais peut-être je te pose la
question alors je je je il faut faut le
vérifier je serai pas catégorique on
vérifier est-ce que tu as trois bouquins
à conseiller à notre communauté
ah
h un livre que j'avais lu rapidement
trop rapidement et que j'ai relu
récemment et qui qui donc que je trouve
vraiment très puissant ave une préciance
une prémonition incroyable dernier livre
de Bruno Lemer voilà tu as trouvé l'ami
très visible non
euh euh c'est Christopher lche la du
narcissisme texte de 79 de sociologue
historien américain assez connu c'est
c'est un peu un classique lâche et est
très étonnant dans ses prémonitions je
recommande à tout le monde de de lire ce
texte il y a une anticipation justement
je reviens à mon un peu cette idée d'une
société sans sur moi en fait qu'est-ce
que ça peut donner une société qui
essaie de de fonctionné de manière
totalement narcissique en considérant
que les
individus voilà ne sont sont ne sont
plus sous une loi commune c'est
Christopher Lash alors tu dis trois
livres c'est
ça
[Musique]
euh allez on on va rester dans les dans
les relectures ou enfin moi je l'avais
pas lu mais on m'a conseillé de le lire
mais c'est un texte qui est déjà assez
qui date un peu c'est polyonnais voyage
au au cœur du malaise français texte qui
avait fait polémique à l'époque et qui
est un texte euh qui pose une question
d'une actualité brûlante c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe si on attaque sous couvert
de SOS Racisme de retour aux origines de
valoriser les origines des immigrés en
creux Dionet c'est quand même une mise
en cause de ce qui fait le creuser
français de ce qui fait l'affe
sociétatiste français de ce qui fait un
peu la marque de fabrique ou la
signature de la nation française c'est
évidemment quelque chose de
très de très abstrait de très subjec
c'est l'idée que la France ne connaît
que des citoyens égaux et bien en fait
valoriser il explique ça et valoriser
dans un contexte de montée de l'extrême
droite on est dans les années 80 et de
monter parallèle de SOS Racisme qui
valorise les origines et bien en fait on
est en train de de d'abîmer vraiment le
récit national et et et et yet dit que
il y a il y a quand même quelque chose
de très très dangereux là-dedans qui
alors il parle pas de guerre civile mais
il dit
qu'effectivement on on va vers des temps
très troubles voyage au cœur du malaise
français paulonis livre des années
80 en faut un trisè alors je je précise
tout de suite c'est c'est des lectures
qui sont qui sont récentes et c'est des
textes que je trouve que je voilà que je
recommande parce que il me semble que
c'est pas nécessairement des textes
toujours très connus Gabriel Martinez
gros historien aussi s'appelle la
fascination du jjihad mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé beaucoup il a
fait un un livre s'appelle la traain des
empires je crois il a travaillé beaucoup
sur les les grandes invasions musulmanes
les invasions de la STEP la fascination
du djihad c'est absolument fascinant
c'est un livre qui s'appuie beaucoup sur
la pensée d'im caldoun
euh probablement le le père des de tous
les sociologues ce ce grand penseur du
monde arabo mususulman euh du un peu qui
est à peu près la l'âge de la
Renaissance pour nous et euh et dit et
et ce que raconte im caldoun que reprend
Martinez gros c'est que une
société ne peut fonctionner finalement
que si elle a une cohésion on revient à
cette idée de d'intérêt général elle a
une cohésion forte et elle est prête à
défendre les armes à la main cette
cohésion et elle est toujours consciente
que
l'inimitié la
guerre peuvent être de retour et ce qu'
et pourquoi il il est fait référence à
im kalalnoun parce qu'im kalalnoun a
vécu
l'effondrement de ces de ces sociétés
notamment d'Andalousie c'est des
sociétés qui étaient des sociétés issu
d'une conquête de peuple du désert très
aguéris qui avaient conquis des sociétés
qui se sont on dirait aujourd'hui notre
vocabulaire que ce sont un peu
bourgeoisé
empâé et qui finalement 3 4 5
générations après n'était plus en mesure
de se défendre et qui veut la paix
prépare la guerre et comme il n'était
plus en mesure de se défendre comme
finalement il n'avait plus le terme
arabe c'est d'assabia c'est de cohésion
de force de cohésion mais en même temps
de croyance très forte qui est relié
entre eux et qui leur permettait d'avoir
un un
un une
raison de d'aller à la guerre ensemble
finalement comme cet Assabia s'était
effondré et bien ces empires se sont
effondrés et voilà c'est ce que rappelle
Martinez gros dans ce dans ce texte et
ça me fait penser à cette expression qui
est très à la mode qui est le vivre
ensemble et je pense que le ce texte de
Martinez Martinez Gabriel Martinez gros
Martinez gros esttant son nom de
famille s'appelle la fascination du
djihad et il traite de cette question de
l'expression du vivre ensemble il dit a
pas de vivre ensemble en fait il y a une
société ne peut tenir que si ceux qui
habitent ensemble dans la cité ou dans
la société donnée sont capables de
mourir côte à côte pour un bien commun
ensemble si ce bien commun disparaît ils
sont pas capables de se défendre les les
uns à côté des autres et bien la cité
disparaît et il y a pas de vivre
ensemble il y aura à mourir séparément
est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes génération une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissable qui restera
sur les réseaux ou là ou là ou là avant
la prochaine tempérte
solaire
[Musique]
euh
l'importance c'est
la c'est la transmission c'est-à-dire
euh
finalement on en revient à cette idée il
faut quelque chose qui qui pour vivre
heureux il faut pas vivre pour soi
paradoxalement caché non pas caché non
plus mais il faut il faut quelque chose
qui qui dépasseindividu c'est ce qui
fait c'est il a il y a il y a une espèce
de de de fuite en avant dans dans dans
un moment très bref qui est ce moment de
de de la vie euh une espèce de fuite en
avant mais cette fuite en avant elle n'a
un sens euh
elle a un sens que si on est précédé par
quelque chose on est suivi par quelque
chose donc je je dirais faites des
enfants faites tout le contraire de ce
que vous raconte le wisme faites des
enfants
transmettez et et recherchez quelque
chose qui vous qui vous dépasse en fait
c'est plus égoïste enfin le le
narcissisme l'idée de vivre pour soi de
rechercher son intérêt de se réaliser
soi-même enfin tout ce délire des
enfants oui j'ai des enfants combien
deux tout ce délire de de de de
développement personnel comme on dit ça
rend malheureux finalement ça rend
malheureux le la la clé d'une vie
réussie c'est quand
même de de transmettre enfin de de de
faire quelqu chose qui va
euh qui qui est plus important que soi
tout simplement guillum Bigo merci merci
[Musique]
sky